now good evening and uh welcome to this
meeting of traffic council's Planning
and Development Committee uh my name is
councilor Barry Stanley and I'm the
chair of this committee uh chair of this
committee before we start the meeting
proper is there anybody in the public
area who intends to film the meeting
okay brilliant in any event we'll be in
broadcast on the council's YouTube
channel they're continuing on to my left
and right our Council officers from
planning legal and highways down both
sides of the table and members of the
committee who are all local councilors
I'll introduce them as they speak
to the gender how to run attendances to
note our attendance and any apologies we
have apologies this evening from
councilors Walsh and accordingly Council
Acton is attending as sub uh thank you
councilor
item two membership of the committee to
note the membership including chair Vice
chair and opposition spokesperson of the
planning and development management
committee for the municipal year 2324 as
agreed by the Council on 24th of May
2023 and attached to this report can
members note this report
I'll take that as a yes thank you
appointment of a subcommittee the
committee has to appoint the town a
Village Green subcommittee comprising
the chair Vice chair and opposition
spokesperson or their nominees for the
municipal year 23-24 could somebody
propose that please thank you councilor
seconded councilor thank you uh
appointed item four terms of reference
to note the terms of reference for the
planning and development management
committee as attached to this report
from the committee note in terms of
reference
yes thank you
item five meeting dates to note the
schedule meeting data laid out in the
report for the committee during the
23-24 municipal year
as agreed by the Council on 24th of May
2023 and the two training sessions can
that be noted
yeah thank you
item six Declarations of Interest
members to give notice of any personal
or prejudicial interest and the nature
of that interest relating to any item on
the agenda in accordance with the
adopted code of conduct does any member
wish to give notice yes true
uh number one is application one zero
nine eight three three
land to east of Warwick Road South Old
Trafford and the second one is one one
zero two eight zero chaiwala 1898 Road
uh thank you Council will you be
recusing yourself at those so yeah would
you believe the meeting for those two
items sorry will you be leaving the
meeting for those yes I will do okay
brilliant thank you Monday yes
Council Baba yeah okay also um
okay brilliant thank you
uh can I also note something for uh just
for noting uh I'm acquainted with the
applicants for 109 337 160 high road
urmston but this will not affect my vote
uh on this evening
item seven minutes oh
sorry Dave thank you chairman yes I just
like to point out that I live close to
the eight Kings Road sales site so I'll
remove myself from the room just like to
point out that I've not had any
involvement in the in the application
thank you thank you Mr Pearson Barry
I want to declare that I'm married to
councilor Kevin Proctor who is speaking
on item
109 337
um 160 high road we have not discussed
this at all because
it's not right to so I'm not recusing
myself because I have no idea what he's
going to be saying okay okay thank you
councilor anymore before we move on
brilliant thank you item seven minutes
to receive and if so determined to
approve is a correct record the minutes
of the meeting held on 11th of May 2023
do you have a proposer
thank you councilor second duck thank
you councilor minutes received item
eight questions from members of the
public we have no questions this evening
item nine additional information reports
to consider a report of the head of
Planning and Development to be tabled at
the meeting the report has been so
tabled item 10 applications for
permission to develop to consider the
attached reports of the head of planning
and development for the following
applications we have seven on the agenda
for tonight the process is the same in
each case the item is introduced by a
member of the planning team if we have
speakers on the item they then speak
next members of the public get three
minutes award members get five minutes
I'll then open the item Up For Debate to
members of the committee only and we
will then come to a decision by a
majority vote given the length of the
agenda I would be very grateful if
members could be as brief as possible
and their contributions this evening and
particularly avoid repeating in detail
points that have already been made thank
you members uh the first item on the
agenda is item
110280 89A
Ayers Road page 213 of the pack and Miss
Milner will get the introduction thank
you Ms Milner
thank you chair
so the first application
um
relates to a site that consists of a
ground floor commercial unit
within an interest property located on
the south side of Earth Road and the
corner of Carlton Street in Old Trafford
the site is located in a predominantly
residential area of Old Trafford
although there are residents so there
are commercial units along Ayers Road
the application site is occupied by a
hot food takeaway known as chai Walla
planning permission was granted in March
1998 for hot food takeaway subject to
the condition that the open hours be
restricted from 12 p.m midday until 10
30 PM in December 1998 Planning
Commission was sought to bury those
approved hours to allow for the unit to
extend the opening hours to midnight
this application was refused by the
council due to the noise and disturbance
from comings and goings to the site in
the late evening hours and this decision
was appealed and dismissed by the
planning inspector who again cited the
extension of the hours into the
sensitive evening hours would be
inappropriate
the current application seeks to vary
the approved plan and permission to
allow for an extension of the opening
hours to operate within the morning time
with the open areas proposed to change
from midday 12
to 10 30 to 8 A.M till 10 30 in the
evening
the application is reported to the
planning committee as it has received
more than six representations contrary
to the officer recommendation
objections received are detailed within
the officer report and within the
additional report available to members
in the public
with the focus of the objections on the
impact of the use and the proposed
extension of errors on residential
amenity of local areas with issues
regarding litter Waste Management noise
and odor from the use and extraction
system noise and disturbance from
customers and disamenity due to parking
and servicing of the unit
in addition objections were received
relating to the time it's taken for the
council to take action on the owner of
Rise hours and the issues with the
extraction system the level of
consultation taking place for the
planning application and the impact of
The Proposal on people with protected
characteristics as well as matters of
Highway Safety
officers are aware that the unit has
been operating outside the approved
errors and following an investigation by
the compliance planning compliance team
the current application is now before
members to consider
also separately to planning
investigations and the council's
environmental health offices have been
investigating the unit over the previous
two years following complaints regarding
the extraction system
follow following and mitigation managers
by the applicant on two occasions
which followed was followed by noise
monitoring at a residential property the
environmental health offices are now
satisfied the extraction equipment no
longer presents a statutory nuisance
issue and have closed the case relating
to the extraction system they raised no
objections to the current application to
extend the hours and are supported of
the conditions proposed by offices to
mitigate the extension of hours
the local Highway Authority are also
consulted and they have not raised an
objection to the occupation
from the extent of comments received
officers appreciate the concerns of
local residents and Ward members
although a number of comments relate to
the general use of the unit as a hot
view takeaway which cannot be addressed
through the current application comments
also do relate to the intensification of
the use and the impact of that extension
of hours
if considered that opening into the
morning would increase the activity at
the side however the increase in opening
times could be mitigated through the
conditions proposed relating to
extraction equipment management of
servicing deliveries and further
clarification on opening hours and trade
consideration of the comments relating
to people with protected characteristics
has also been undertaken however they
did not relate to a specific individual
and as a whole it's not considered that
in this case the equality's
considerations would change the planning
balance
the scheme has been assessed against the
development plan and the material
consideration of The Proposal
consideration also given to the
representations received the scheme is
considered to comply with the
development plan as a whole and is
therefore recommended for approval
subject to the conditions as outlined in
the committee report thank you chair
uh thank you Miss Milner we have three
speakers against the proposal
um Ms Houston and councilors Hurst and
councilor Taylor
um have three of you between you decided
in which order you will speak
first of all are the three people in the
room
who would like to go first
okay
thank you miss you have you come to the
microphone you'll get three minutes to
speak
um then we'll start the clock once you
press the button on the microphone to
begin speaking if you go over three
minutes I'll politely ask you to wrap up
your remarks so in your own time thank
you Miss Houston
speaking on behalf of myself and many
Old Trafford residents who've been
significantly adversely impacted by the
Chihuahua development since it set up
operations in the summer of 2021 I wish
to strongly object on behalf of myself
and these residents we've been involved
in extensive consultations and
complaints about the issues caused by
this business for the last two years
with the owners and with various traffic
Council units however no progress has
been made
the 21 representations clearly explain
the issues that we've been facing over
the last two years and extending the
opening times of this business for four
extra hours per day for seven days a
week will greatly exacerbate these
adverse impacts I understand it has been
brought to my attention a noise impact
assessment was carried out by chowola in
March 2022 that concluded the levels to
be way above twice the
um allowed levels which is 10 decibels
higher than the background noise to the
best of my knowledge uh some mitigation
was carried out in terms of a silencer
and the levels were turned down that has
gone way back up again and I can vouch
for myself and other residents that
those levels are extremely high and
extremely disturbing I do not spend time
in my garden anymore uh the whistling
noise is throughout my house or my
bedroom I spend my time in the front
rooms of the house now it's been
absolutely awful living with this
situation and other members uh residents
who are here can can vouch for that as
well extending the hours will just
increase this this this distressed
residence basically the traffic problems
have been awful as well and anti-social
behavior these have increased massively
since this business opened
um one resident refers to try one now
the the their street Carlton Street as a
chai wallet drive through this is a
national chain it's nothing like the
local businesses that are there now
which are small local businesses which
we love and they've really benefited the
area this is a completely different
um category of hot food takeaway and
Cafe uh the littering of poor Waste
Management has been awful the bins and
pellets continually stored in blocking
the Alleyways these things have not been
resolved they have not been resolved the
statutory noise impact I had a recording
done in my house
um the the equipment is not picking
things up a noise impact assessment is
what's needed here and I'm sure those
levels will come out way above what is
acceptable
um to not adverse the impact on
residents mental health physical health
and quality of life
um the disproportionate effect on groups
with protecting characteristics is that
those who are house bands such as
disabled people elderly people are stuck
in their homes with this disturbance I'm
spending a lot of time out I visit
relatives friends a lot I do not use my
garden I used to use it constantly
um you know I'm actually considering
it's very charge is very hard I'm going
to leave the area now and move out as a
result of this
um I just want to say that there's a
local government Ombudsman complaint
that was submitted and the responses due
back very soon uh one important concern
and as far as I can see the Town and
Country planning regulations 2021
amendment is does state that a sewer
generous category of use needs planning
permission this was not gained when this
business was set up
um I cannot see how this can be
separated from this application to
extend the uh the the hours
um and the benefits of the I try to
think of the benefits of extending the
hours of this business obviously people
could
you wrap up here what's up can order um
their food for longer
um but I I would suggest that we need to
weigh these up with the ongoing
significant disadvantages to Residents
which have been absolutely awful I
haven't had long to say much but I've
submitted representation so a 21 there
and these will explain this thank you
okay thank you
uh either councilor Hurst or councilor
Taylor next
thank you councilor Hurst you will get
five minutes when you press the button
and start speaking
thank you
hello I'm the newly elected councilor to
the Old Trafford Ward where I've been a
resident for 22 years
one of the first issues that was brought
to my attention by residents was the
misery caused by the local branch of
chiwala
for those not familiar with chaiwalla
it's an international brand with
branches throughout the world it sells
fast food in various drinks it's
extremely popular and the food is
delicious no one's denying that the air
Road branch is glamorous especially when
compared to its neighbors but notably
for a totally refitted pseudo modern
building it's got no disabled access and
no toilet at all
it's listed as a hot food takeaway but
actually it's a large 20-seat Cafe with
a busy delivery trade and numerous
people driving to the area to collect
their takeaways is extremely successful
and unfortunately local people and
businesses are the victims of that
success
road is a mixed residential and shopping
parade you can see that from the
pictures chiwala is next door to and at
the end of a residential street across
the road is a small business
the other shops in his road are
predominantly family-run small food
businesses that are diverse and often
extraordinary esroad isn't always a
pretty sight but it needs sprucing up
rather than an influx of franchises
I've contacted most of the nearby local
residents and many more from surrounding
streets have contacted me as have local
businesses
they have been unanimous in their dismay
at the effects chai wall has had on them
excessively noisy extraction unit
unpleasant smells litter illegal parking
people urinating in the alley bins
obstructing residents and block drains
are all the themes of the objections
sent into the planning portal the 12
o'clock opening time at least gives some
respite in the morning extending the
opening hours will mean residents face
the daily disruption from the moment
they wake or open up
it's been made clear that this meeting
is to discuss the increase in hours not
the business as a whole but the effect
of increasing opening hours cannot be
separated from the current experience of
the business child wallet has caused
misery to Residents and local businesses
and several have told me that if
extended opening hours are approved they
will move away despite loving their
homes and the community
clungy have also commented in their
observations that many of the objections
are outside the remit of planning that
they are the responsibility of
environmental health building
regulations the council and the police
what I would say to this is we have to
look at the body the balance of positive
and negative outcomes if this extension
is two hours is approved approval means
on the positive side people can buy
pasties and omelettes for an extra four
hours a day but that comes with a
negative of 30 more misery for residents
and extra pressure on all the services
who are supposedly responsible for the
noise smell dangerous parking and lack
of amenities who are allowed have been
unable to effectively enforce any of the
infractions to the point that as
mentioned residents have been forced to
go to the local government ombudsman
I'd also like to point out that Old
Trafford is home to many vulnerable
residents on the streets surrounding
chaiwala there are many elderly and
disabled residents there are also high
levels of poverty in Old Trafford these
residents are much more likely to be
digitally excluded and so unable to
access this Arena a planning committee
so they can't submit planning objections
or know where to complain about nuisance
we cannot say they are not
disproportionately affected because
they've not been able to give their
views and I've come to the final and
perhaps key point I wish you to consider
chai Wallace planning allows it to open
from 12 o'clock for around two years
it's been opening from eight o'clock
illegally even advertising this on the
door I counted five delivery drivers and
four families entering chai wallow
within 40 minutes very early last Sunday
morning
if you grant these additional hours to a
business owner who's clearly
demonstrated he has no regard for
planning conditions building regulations
or environmental health what release
next move be open until midnight two
o'clock and why should residents have
any faith that anything will be done
about this
I'd ask the planning committee to think
about the residents and other local
businesses and say no to this approval
I've asked that chai Walla proves it can
be a good neighbor that it considers its
amenities such as its access installs
toilet facilities which it should do as
it has more than 10 seats and IT
addresses its noise levels litter and
anti-social Behavior
when it proves that it's a good neighbor
and it's prepared to contribute and just
not not just take from the community we
will welcome chai Walla like we do other
businesses but at the moment it's not a
good neighbor and allowing extending
opening hours will not benefit your
people of Old Trafford
thank you counselor
uh councilor sailor
[Music]
the same drill you'll get five minutes
from when you press the button
thanks
thank you chair thank you for allowing
me to speak to the committee regarding
this planning proposal
neighborhoods are enhanced by thriving
businesses and it is true to say that
the chai Walla Cafe on Ayers Road has
been a popular addition to the
hospitality and Catering outlets in the
area however this has come at Great
detriment discomfort disadvantage and
inconvenience to its neighbors
in this proposal chai Walla has
requested a change to their current
planning consent to allow them to extend
their current opening hours however they
are in fact already doing this in
flagrant breach of their current
permissions I would like to reinforce
the points made by councilor hurt to
oppose the granting of this request
number one axis and egress and
maneuvering and operational space around
this business are inadequate in this
location this is evidenced by waste
management companies persistently
driving to the business the wrong way in
adjacent one-way Carlson Street as road
is already a congested busy road parking
there is no off street parking for this
business and this is on the corner as
I've said a one-way street we have
received numerous complaints about
idling cars from early in the morning
until late at night Road blocking
residents including disabled residents
being unable to access their homes lack
of access for emergency vehicles and
aggression to Residents from customers
collecting their takeaways
environmental issues chai Walla has
external fans which start at 6 30 a.m
and stop after 11 pm they are noisy and
clearly audible to nearby residents
whilst inside their homes they're
unsightly and circulate unpleasant stale
cooking odors waste disposal the
business has an adequate space for bins
and cites them in Alleyways residents
would be sanctioned for this there is
increased Street litter including
wrapping from delivery pellets cooking
oil has been disposed of down drains
causing blocking a severe environmental
health hazard yet Trafford environmental
health has not seen reasons to oppose
this inclusivity and access there is no
access to the premises for wheelchair
users and there is no toilets or any
hygiene facilities available for patrons
additionally we would ask the committee
and officers to re-examine the
consultation process in this case what
assessment has there been regarding the
type of development this is deemed to be
in line with UK government guidance on
consultation and pre-decision matters
which was published in 2022 and how have
our residents being made aware of this
the problems chair associated with this
business are numerous and extensive they
are pervasive and severely impacting on
our residence quality of life chai
wallet has not adhered to planning
permissions previously granted and this
should not be overlooked or excused
granting permission to formally extend
its opening hours will only exacerbate
and deepen the problems we have already
highlighted there will be more
disturbance to Residents earlier in the
day and increased Road Safety danger
particularly for children going to
school
until chai wallet can prove itself to be
responsible and respectful neighbor and
adhere to its existing planning content
no further permissions should be granted
in doing so this sets a very dangerous
precedent for other businesses to
operate outside of their consent and
ride roughshod over residents we urge
you in the strongest terms to oppose
this proposal thank you chair
thank you councilor before I go to the
officers for some uh comments and what's
been said so far
um is Mr
there's Mr Clark present
s
and the drill is the same you get three
minutes from when you begin to when you
press the microphone if you overrun
we'll ask you politely to wrap up okay
thank you
um good evening everyone
um first of all thank you very much
that's the first time I've heard a lot
of these comments
um there's a few things I wanted to
quickly clear number one 630 our first
staff member enters the shop at quarter
past seven and it takes about 45 minutes
to prepare
the the business ready for trade at
eight o'clock
um my name is tayab I'm a local I live a
couple miles away from the store and I
attend the three local mosques in the
area I've known the area as I've grown
up in there and I've got lots of family
and friends in the ward I've been in
business for about 20 years now I've
employed over a thousand people and not
once have I had have ever had any issues
in terms of employment I've always
looked after my customers my staff and
suppliers I'm also non-exact director at
Lancia cricket and I do a lot of work in
terms of bringing women's and girls into
Cricket as well as working with people
from disadvantaged backgrounds into
qriket so a lot of what I've just heard
now goes completely against what I stand
for
chai Manor has got 83 stores in the UK
it started off by three friends in
Leicester in the documentation it
mentions hundreds of Stores
um and it mentions hot food takeaway
it's such a cafe license so you know you
guys know a lot more of them myself Cafe
licenses used to be the old A3 and it's
now Class E so I've got six other stores
in Greater Manchester which we don't
need to apply a license for as long as
in the commercial premises so I couldn't
open it in a house but just like this
where you've got trade going on I'm able
to open at 8am
um moving on
in terms of us not putting back into the
community you know we we've sponsored
mosques we work closely with WETA which
is women's
um women empowered through Arts um we
last week celebrating National carers
week by donating chai to St James's
church we we employ local people so we
have 13 people at the employee of which
10 work then live within 10 minutes
walking distance I'm really upset today
to be honest because I'm someone that
gives my phone number so I've got a lady
we're in number 89. I've got a lady that
lives at 85 who shared some issues in
terms of noise and so on the first thing
I did was give my mobile number and say
look you know anytime you need to call
me I'm here to fix it and I've got
responses from her saying she's really
happy with this situation so you know
I'm I definitely want to work with
councilors and neighbors to make this
better I've got 30 seconds so the
planning department have recommended to
approve our application the conditions I
believe are very fair one of the
conditions is no no cooking can happen
before eight o'clock that means I
wouldn't be able to open for trade
before nine o'clock and between nine and
midday every day as Road has the most
parking available and it's the quieter
because people are at work on their
daily chores and so on we operate a
daily litter pick and we can share this
which we actually document how many
pieces of child are litter it's never
been more than five
and I could increase I could double my
income by opening a fast food chicken
restaurant open between 12 and 10 pm
double my income but I believe chaiwella
has a lot more to give and I do want to
make this you know I'm a part of the
same Community we breathe the same air
so I really want to work with everyone
that's against this and make it a better
place so our time's up but they're my
key points thank you thank you
before I asked members to contribute
could ask Miss Miller could you comment
on some of the main points made by by
the speakers mainly think around noise
nuisance in the streets that kind of
thing good
the noise and disturbance we have worked
closely with environmental health it has
taken
um
they have been investigating for two
years and we are speaking to them quite
regularly and
even you know up until today our
compliance teams have been working with
them and we are monitoring the unit as
it stands currently they had closed
their case in relation to noise from the
extraction system following um their
ongoing investigation
if that has changed what we are
proposing are set out in the officer
report the committee report is a
condition to
ask for an updated
um survey on noise and odor and that
would then fix the kind of the level at
which we expect the extraction system to
operate for the lifetime of the
development and I'd also say that in
relation to the previous planning
permission it did not have from 1998 it
did not have a
um delivering servicing condition so
there was no
um control by by planning offices on how
that unit would be serviced and received
deliveries we've now sought to apply
that condition we do consider that would
be a reasonable condition given the
intensification of the use and the
potential impact on residents so we have
asked for for that to be submitted and
approved and that would be approved in
consultation with our environmental
health offices and our highways offices
and being mindful of the
um the road layout and the constraints
of the site if then the use was to
operate outside of that we could then
take steps to enforce some breach of
conditions so just to reiterate that is
currently not regulated and
in regards to some of the other points
raised I appreciate it sounds
frustrating when we say you know that's
not you know dealt with by planning so
you know if people are driving up the
road the wrong way we can't we do not
have the legislative Paris to to take
any action than that equally if people
are parking on the pavement we cannot
get involved in that we must look at the
the land use and the impact of that the
behavior of customers is not something
that we can regulate equally in terms of
comments uh regarding it being a
national franchise we cannot look at who
the brand is we're looking purely at the
land use so whether it is a national
brand or a local company set up by the
neighbor we must assess it in the same
light
um
however frustrating that is we that we
are looking at land use
thank you Miss Mill any member wishing
to speak
counteractin
thank you chair I mean I've listened to
um both sides of the argument
um and
for me I think the the the the case that
has been put forward by the councilors
and
um and from the resident uh he is quite
strong and that clearly the nearby
residents
um feel that this
um business is actually disadvantaging
the residents that's a nearby residence
and I think that has to be addressed and
um
I think there was a reason why
in the first place uh that there was
time limits put on to the initial
application and clearly I think the
owners of the business
um
doesn't do their case any good
whatsoever when they ignore their
existing conditions because it bolds
really badly on the you know on your
business quite frankly and I believe you
know and that has been ignored for 20
months and that is a long time for
residents to have to put up with that
and and you know you say about you know
putting the breakfast and on on all of
all of that
um that you you have to
um you know open earlier well you
shouldn't have been opened at all and
that was the case really
um so so for me I I wouldn't want to
support the recommendations on on the
paper
was that a proposal counselor to go
against officer recommendation yeah okay
thank you
so I think Council Council Welton was
the next two did you did you indicate
yeah
this is a this is a really really tricky
one and I and we have uh clearly there's
a lot of feet a lot a lot of feeling in
the local community about this you know
this application or maybe more
specifically
um regarding the the the the the cafe
and the way or the um the outlets and
the way it's being run
um itself uh
what I think we need to get down to
obviously is the planning you know the
planning reasons
um you know if we were to to go against
officer recommendation we have to come
up with a good planning reason
um
for that we've been told by the officers
that we can't you know look at who the
cafe is or the brand and that kind of
thing
um you know you have to look at the The
Proposal that's on the paper and that
makes it very difficult to take into in
into consideration those those concerns
of you know anti-social behavior
um bin management all those kind of
things you know that there are
conditions which which are dealing with
that I think if there is if there is one
concern then it is the noise concern or
obviously by opening longer hours you've
got a
um
you you know that the noise of the of
the
Outlet operating is affecting residents
that's affecting residents um
residential immunity
um so I think that's probably the
strongest suit if uh you know if we were
to to go against officer recommendation
having said that at the same time if
somebody was who want you know if you
didn't know the name of the cafe if
somebody was to propose to open a cafe
there that opens at eight o'clock in the
morning and you know serves a full
English or whatever that would pretty
much automatically say all through and
that's the you know I think that's our
problem here is that is that actually
having a cafe there you know that opens
at that time you know if you don't know
anything about the business that would
get through and if we this go if this
went to appeal then that would be what
the planning of the um planning
inspector would be looking at you know
and uh and it would be very liable to to
lose that that appeal if we're basically
just going on on the noise issue which
is something that is being dealt with in
the conditions
um
so it's a really tough one I'll listen
to what everyone else is saying
um before making my decision thank you
Council Proctor
thank you chair
what frustrates me is this business was
given planning consent to open from noon
yet for 20 months it's been opening from
8 A.M and we've heard how
a member of Staff arrives at quarter
past seven but yet food can't be ready
until nine
but it's open at eight for food so
there's a complete contradiction between
what one person's told us
and what the business actually
advertises on its door there's no point
in putting a planning condition on
anything
if then that business or that house
Builder whoever completely ignores it
and decides to do what they want to do
instead and this has been a flagrant
um
ignoring
what the consent was
and having listened to the resident and
the two councilors objections
I liked second
um Council Upton's motion to
um overturn
officers recommendations thank you okay
uh thank you councilor Council minutes
thank you chair
um having listened to both sides I mean
the part I know that this is not part of
the this would be part of enforcement
about it opening outside of the hours
that have been
um have been approved in the past of
midday
um till till 10 30 but um if it's
as as in fact the owner has admitted
effectively here saying that it's you
know he's serving from nine o'clock in
the morning well that's clearly not
12 noon is it so
I think that given the residents have
had literally I know that that is
obviously part of the the neighbors have
actually had an experience of what
um what is being proposed here they
literally have experiences for for some
time and
clearly it's not it's bringing them a
lot of misery and I think that when we
have this many number uh there's not
many residents
um
saying that it's affecting their lives
so dramatically I don't think that we
can I think a loss of immunity is
absolutely what's happening here they
are losing their ability to have
um some peace and quiet effectively for
their day and what we're saying is even
if we did if it was enforcing the the
restricted State as they are they just
need to be in force and then at least
they'd have peace in the morning but to
go from 8 A.M
um I I don't think it's something that I
could support I think it's just bringing
misery to people that live nearby so I
will be voting against just on grounds
of loss of immunity of the of the
residents nearby thank you
uh thank you councilor anyone else Mr
Speaker
[Music]
thank you thank you chair if I could
just uh clarify and remind members that
the behavior of the applicant and any
previous breaches of planning control
you must not weigh that in the balance
so you must you cannot refuse an
application on the basis so you don't
trust the applicant to
um to uh comply with the conditions that
are imposed
um also remind you that the the number
of objections again is not Material it
is what they say and also just reiterate
the point that a lot of the the issues
raised are not within the scope of this
application to deal with
um I hear what members are saying about
their concerns and and if you do refuse
it I would just
um point to councilor welton's point
about being selective about where you go
with that as opposed to
um taking everything you've heard this
evening
um as as being the reasons for refusal
uh focus into one particular issue which
you do think is closest to the to the
one that the planning can control thank
you
thank you thank you Rebecca
I've listened really hard to the the
arguments both sides of this and I take
um great optimism by the fact the
applicant has said that tonight is the
first time he's heard about any of these
any of these complaints
and it's for that reason which I am
inclined to vote against the application
for the extended hours because what that
will do if the applicants are generating
what he says it will allow him to work
with the the local residents to arrive
at a solution which a future date you
can bring back to the committee and
reapply for the Planning Commission and
without the level of objection you've
got here perhaps I mean I can't judge
what will happen in the future but it
would be a less difficult a less
difficult meeting
a second
I'll say this because if the committee
could go with what council Welter
suggested that it's residential ability
on the grounds of noise
um from the extraction fan and from
activity at the premises is that is that
correct that's what I was suggesting
yeah
okay
yeah we're we're happy that that's okay
that's pretty okay then so the proposal
is that we
um vote against the application against
officers recommendation could all those
in favor show
foreign
against
one against are you abstaining
can I just make a point here from the uh
before before the legal officer makes it
you are allowed to abstain
however the purpose of this committee is
to make a decision so I would recommend
that you make a decision it's up to you
but you to abstain seems to be a big job
to the committee but it's up to you okay
so the two abstentions
okay
thank you
uh the next highest one agenda is
uh 160 High Road urmston that's on page
one of your pack and Mr day will give
the introduction
we've got two councilors absence at the
moment
update and you don't get the counselves
thank you councilor
okay
yeah it's nice we're going the opposite
way from
this way
and then just use the arrows
okay
[Music]
thank you
okay yeah thank you chair
um
this application relates to the
development of land currently occupied
by a single story vacant industrial
Warehouse
I'll just put a slight plan on the
screen the building is surrounded by
four Court parking to the front and a
large storage yard to the rear
the immediate surrounding area is
predominantly residential comprising of
two-story semi-detached and terrorist
dwellings
the application proposes the erection of
five three-story terrorist drawings
following demolition of the existing
building
with off street parking provided to the
front of each unit
the proposed dwellings are to be
constructed of a mix of white and buff
brickwork with a metal steel standing
seam roof
the application is reported to the
planning and development management
committee as it has been called in by
councilor Kevin Proctor
the application has received lesser
objection from three neighboring
addresses
the main concerns raised relate to
overlooking security and matters of
detail regarding boundary treatments
I'll just quickly run through
the plans
so there you can see the existing
building on the application site
and the existing elevations
of that building
uh this is the proposed layout
of the developments so you can see
there's five terrorist properties across
the width of the site with one parking
space each to the front
um and the small amounts of landscaping
breaking up some of those parking spaces
Gardens to the rear obviously the site
boundary at the rear is
um splayed and therefore the depth of
the gardens reduces as you as you move
further to the east
this is the street scene elevation and
the rear elevation
so you can see that the development is
taller than the neighboring
um
properties
there's obviously uh
balconies timber timber balconies on the
front
and it's not very clear on that drawing
but on the rear elevation there is a
large Dormer running across the the
whole width of the elevation
side elevations so you can see from this
drawing that the the side elevations
that the roof form is asymmetrical with
a steeper slope on the front roof slope
um and there's obviously the large
Dormer on the rear of the of the
buildings of the dwellings
which would be seen to some extent in
the street scene
um internal layout plans showing
um three-bedroom properties
and some photographs of the existing
site obviously the existing industrial
building and the hard standing to the
front of it and you can see the
two-story Residential Properties on
either side of that
um the proposed dwellings would fail to
meet adopted guidelines in relation to
distances to rear boundaries and window
to window distances with neighboring
properties
as such there would be under overlooking
and loss of privacy in relation to those
properties
in terms of visual immunity the
elevational design roof form height
scale massing and material to the
buildings is considered by officers to
be at odds with the character of the
area
and it's considered it would appear
visually in Congress
the proposed development would also
result in a site Frontage dominated by a
large amount of hard surfacing and
parked cars with a lack of provision for
soft landscaping and tree planting
officers therefore consider that the
pros development would have a
detrimental impact on the character and
visual appearance of the street scene
and the surrounding area
another reason for refusal was
recommended on the main reports on the
grounds that the application failed to
demonstrate there's a suitable surface
water drainage scheme would be provided
you can see in the additional
information report that a revised
drainage scheme has been submitted now
um and the lead Local Food Authority is
therefore removed its objection on this
basis subject conditions so this third
reason for refusal has now been omitted
from the recommendation
so as the council does not currently
have an immediately available five-year
supply of housing land with tilted
balance
in mppf paragraph 11d2 would apply
The Proposal would create five new
family dwellings in a sustainable
Brownfield location
and would therefore make a modest
contribution towards the birds housing
Supply
the development would also generate a
small amount of economic benefit during
construction work
and in addition the agent has stated
that the development would provide
environmental benefits through the
provision of energy efficient homes
although details are precisely how these
measures would be incorporated into the
development have not been submitted and
therefore this is considered to carry
limited weight
in weighing the planning balance it is
considered that the adverse impacts of
the developments in relation to
residential amenity and Design
has set out above wood significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
granting planning permission when
assessed against the policies of the
mppf taken as a whole is therefore
recommended that Planning Commission
should be refused
sure thank you Mr day is Mr Honus in the
public area would you care to come to
the microphone Mr Hamas
you're probably getting the drill by now
you can start a rear wheel starter timer
once you press the button if you go over
three minutes then I'll probably ask you
to finish your remarks okay in your own
time thank you
can everyone hear me okay
yeah uh good evening everyone I'm John
Honis so I'm here here with my fiance
Emma Ashdown uh thank you for inviting
us along tonight uh just to clarify
myself and Emma live in the property
just uh directly south of the site uh So
the plan properties are effectively just
at the end of our garden
um we have several serious concerns
about the plan properties uh first of
all I'd just like to stress that we're
not objecting just out of principle
um we are being constructive and we're
suggesting solutions to our concerns
we'd like to see changes made to the
plans because we feel they are
completely inadequate so first concern
is uh the potential properties will be
directly behind our house overlooking
our garden and property from the plans
it is clear that the new buildings will
be able to see directly into our rooms
the plan state that the windows are at
an oblique angle which prevent us from
being overlooked however this is
incorrect the orientation of the new
properties means that they have a clear
line of sight into our house and garden
the new properties are three stories
high the windows in the top bedrooms are
a height of about seven meters which is
significantly higher than the windows of
the existing neighboring properties
um this is to the detriment of the
immunity of our property as mentioned in
the officers report
um so there is nothing in the plans to
prevent our property from being
overlooked this could easily be solved
by for example some frosted glass
screens at the sides of the windows of
the new properties and by high fences or
trees at the end of the South ends of
the gardens of the new Properties or
more appropriately building a two-story
property instead of a three-story one
the second issue is we're very concerned
about security
the alleyway allows potentially simple
access to our property especially due to
the hidden nature of the alleyway this
could even be Public Access through the
alleyway gate as it is highly likely to
be left unlocked because of the amount
of people who will be using it and
coming and going and this is also
actually a point raised by greater
Manchester police which is in the
officers report as well a good solution
to this would be a self-closing gate
with key fob access only to the
residents and it should be forbidden to
prop it open
the third point is we're unhappy with
the revised bin proposal as they are
still too close to our property the bins
are right behind our garden and we're
concerned about the nuisance of bad
odors that this will cause furthermore
the plan is inadequate because it
doesn't state that any waste storage
will be completely prohibited in the
alleyway area it's highly likely that
residents will use the alleyway for bins
or waste storage especially again due to
the hidden nature of this Alleyway the
best solution to this we feel would be
to move the bin storage to the front or
north side of the plan properties
the fourth issue is we live in a quiet
cul-de-sac behind the property and we're
concerned about the noise from the
additional five sets of residents that
will be right behind our house the plans
are completely inadequate in terms of
any soundproofing consideration for our
property or our neighboring properties
um again high fences or trees in The
Gardens of these plant properties would
be a potential solution to this
uh and our final point is that we have
trees at the back of our garden that
could potentially block sunlight into
the south facing Gardens of the plant
properties I'd just like to ask what is
the expected solution to this in the
plans because there isn't one thanks for
your attention
thank you Miss Taurus
handshaw in the public area
again you get three minutes once you
press the microphone button and we'll
um ask you to bloody wrap up if you'll
go over thank you presidential
it's all right yeah yeah good evening
chair members of the committee my name
is George ensure I'm Mimi wife Kath I've
owned the property
at 160 honey Road for 30 years we're
local people wanting to make best use of
the site for the environment and the
community there has been no Employments
on the site for 10 years and we've
witnessed a rapid decline in commercial
activity in the area the science is now
redundant
the warehouse is in a derelict State its
appearance is incongruous
it is totally surrounded by hard
standing IT Supplies on the landscape
such buildings can attract anti-social
Behavior
and remove the feeling of safety for
local residents
we approached Hannah Dixon a certified
passive house designer three years ago
to create a sustainable development
the choice of materials minimizes CO2
emissions
window openings and orientations glazing
and shading have all been designed to
enable upgrading to passive house
the 2020 Trafford carbon neutral action
plan advises that the adoption of
passive house and similar approaches
should be encouraged through the
planning system there is a climate
crisis to ignore this advice or do we
make best use of it the houses are being
carefully designed to provide
comfortable healthy living space for
young families
they're modern and contemporary
they are affordable lifetime homes with
Simplicity of build they create maximum
use of space and accessibility for
everyone fuel poverty can be eliminated
replacing the existing Warehouse with
these houses will have no industrial
detrimental effects on the area
Trafford strategic planning have
confirmed that this is not an over
development
we consider that the proposal
would have no detrimental effects on the
visual immunity and character of the
Street Scene It would cause no harm to
local residents the scheme complies with
policy L7 in September 2022 there was a
public consultation at the site 100
leaflets were distributed including 23
and 25 Lodge Avenue there were no
objections the application is in line
with national policy and local policies
one two four five and seven
it will reduce the short following new
housing it will contribute to the Target
of 80 of new housing on Brownfield sites
the development is appropriate in its
setting and is not an over development
the local Authority should encourage the
use of passive house and similar
approaches
the houses do not directly Overlook any
properties at the rear
there have been no recorded public
objections
the design is accessible and adaptable
beyond the current building rigs the
scheme supports Trafford core strategy
the location and design supports the use
of local transport walking and cycling
it meets trafford's carbon emissions
Target
this is an opportunity to deliver low
carbon well-designed houses for young
families on a Brownfield side close to
Hermiston Town Center
thank you
thank you potential
Council Proctor
use I'm sure you know we'll get five
minutes
yes thank you chair
um
I've been aware of this printing
application for quite quite some time
now and I'm very supportive of it
um and this is why I asked for the call
in when I heard that there's an officer
recommendation recommendation to refuse
I think it's an exciting proposal which
is raising the bar for Construction and
design and it's a very very high
standard
Innovative and well thought out plans
for the site and I share his enthusiasm
for a scheme which could a real positive
outcome for residents in urmston and the
people who ultimately live there
the development meets most of the
council's wider objectives
providing good quality five units of
family accommodation on a Brownfield
site with the added bonus of energy
efficient features
to help with the cost of living for
those families and also a bike store to
encourage cycling
in addition it would generate a small
amount of economic activity in the area
in connection with the construction
process
the homes will also be designed to m42
standard which sets a highest standard
for accessible homes which is broader
equivalent to the lifetime home standard
I understand that this is the second
time the application has been submitted
the applicant made a previous
application in 2021 and since then has
been working hard to meet all the
objections from the planning team
it's my view they have done it so much
they possibly can and demonstrated a
higher degree of flexibility and
willingness to compromise to meet the
issues read by officers concerns about
the plans
as the report correctly States it's
Council that does not currently have an
immediately available five years supply
of housing land and therefore the Tilted
balance balance and ppf paragraph 11d2
would apply
while outlining some of these many
benefits to the scheme the conclusion is
that in weighing the plan and balance it
is considered that the adverse impacts
of development are set out in report
would significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits granted permission
when assessed against the policies of
nppf taken as a whole it's ever
recommended offices the following
permissions refused
I would disagree with this conclusion
The Wider benefits are clear and I would
suggest that the adverse implicats are
not very significant weak or Highly
Questionable
the first objection by height scale
massing roof form manipulation design
fenestration of materials and its layout
including the large area of house
stunning and parking spaces and the lack
of scope for boundary achievement and
still slump keeping aside from news
results in in Congress over dominant
with the obstructive Inc incoherent form
of development which would have a
detrimental impact in the character and
visual appearance of the streets scene
the relevant Point here is the highest
higher Road Street Scene is rapidly
changing from historically larger
industrial business to residential use
and again that background development
fits in well with the change and is not
out of place with other newer properties
in terms of the height of the
development other other neighboring
properties on higher Road can be seen
which are higher than this level
the number of parking spaces have been
set to a minimum requirements to meet
the car speakers required there is a
minimum heart standing with one space
per dwelling
applicants has done a good job in trying
to fit the development into the street
scene with high degree of scale
to support this video I would add that
that we can run a consultation event to
local residents in September 22 which I
also attended and all those people
attended the comments were all positive
also just to add the three letters of
objections mentioned in the report were
actually questions about boundaries and
other matters so the report gives
misleading view about the local level of
opposition which the committee should be
aware of the complaints this evening's
the first time I've heard that
the second application relates to
immunity in states by reason of
proximity to the proposery main habitual
room windows linked to Common grounders
of 23 and 25 Hazel Grove and 18 George
Street with results in overdue
overlooking and loss of privacy to rear
Gardens
habitual room windows those properties
the Zeppelin of the immunity that
occupies the homes could reasonably
expect to enjoy
looking at their plans I do not think
this would be the case and the
application applicants has done much
possibly to mitigate any impact of
looking impact
the guideline distance is the rear
boundary of the properties fractionally
under and not mandatory none of the
houses are directly overlooked so the
window to window comment is not relevant
the one half of a house which was within
30 meters of the real properties is at
34 degrees just questioning pan replies
to these I was going to Convention on
about the drainage issues but that's
been removed Now by Mr day so uh I will
ignore that just in summary I believe
that the Tipping balance the application
should be in favor of Acceptance in
light and the urgent need to provide
family accommodation to in Trafford and
Portmore broadcast science the orc the
the scheme also compute stipulately the
cost of living prices through NGO
efficient terms I hope that committee
can improve is
reject the application and improve this
application thank you thank you
councilor people ask members to speak Mr
Dakin just thank you just to make some
comments again on the boundary distance
between up at the rear of the house
yes
um
I mean it's important to to bear in mind
that the uh
the application at the rear uh the the
proposed development at the rear is
clear clearly three stories with the
Dormer with the bedroom windows and the
tormos so
it sounds about normal standards
um for such which is set out in the new
residential development supplementary
planning guidance
um
we would normally expect a 27 meter
distance across rear boundaries are set
out in those standards plus three meter
additional for
the additional story height so that
would actually
um
uh come to it to a potential distance
across
um from Main habits between main
laboratory and windows of
um
30 meters
obviously in this case it's it's very
significantly
um less than that
um
in terms of the actual distance to
Garden boundaries again
the normal distance for two-story
properties is ten and a half meters with
with the additional Second Story Windows
the required distance would normally be
13.5
meters so
um
I just turned to the actual
just as I set out in the report the
window to window distance would be
approximately 20 meters
um
and the distance to the boundary
certainly in in the end plot the
easternmost plot would only be about
seven meters as opposed to a requirement
of 13.5
meters so it's significantly under the
distance
uh thank you Mr Lee that's fine uh any
member wish to speak Council minutes
I was going to ask that exactly but
thank you very much for answer
um what I was going to say is that I
think that on balance
um I think that absolutely in agreement
with the um with the offices on this one
I think that we've got the roof um being
higher the roof uh being a different uh
pitch at the front to you know how it
looks it will look different it won't
look it won't fit with the street scene
um it being and then the height of it I
think um I mean I know we can't say
Obviously what what would want instead
but I think Master do want a Brownfield
development I do want houses on this on
this plot I just don't think this is the
right development
um I think it's too high I think the
scale massing of it
um along with the proximity to the the
back of the the properties at the rear
um it would it would be too much so I
would be proposing that we refuse this
application thank you thank you
councilor Council Maitland
um I too agree with councilor minis
actually on on this
um I've been to see the site and it is
quite overbearing I feel and that that's
the image I I got I don't agree with the
officers uh with regards to the front of
the building and the lack of Green Acres
the houses that are on each side are
exactly the same anyway so I don't
understand that bit but I think the the
overlooking in them as the massing would
be a little bit too much
um I think the developer needs to talk
to the neighbors the people at the back
to see how they maybe can come to some
sort of conclusion but yeah add second
uh Council minutes okay thank you
councilman
I tend to actually agree with what's
been said at this moment in time
um I don't think there would need to be
too much changes uh to you know get us
into a position where we could support
it and I think I think the resident made
some really strong points you know about
the old but
overlooking of the houses and the
security you know the police don't
always comment but they have commented
commented they're coming
[Applause]
um
on this particular application and I
think you know we need to listen to that
so my my view is with some tweaking of
the development this could go get
through the planning but at the moment I
don't think it could
thank you councilor Council Proctor
thank you chair I'm guessing you're Mark
still on
I'm
I'm disagree with my colleagues
I also know how I wrote fairly well and
houses on the other side of the road
maybe 20 yards further on a tall
Victorian houses
this is on a Brownfield site tick that
box
the lifetime homes
that's amazing
they are they are
using not meeting or but using passive
house standards which will bring the
heating costs down
so much for whoever lives in these
properties I think we can put some
conditions
rather than refusing outright we can put
some conditions
about
um
one one of the comments talks about
having
um a far block
so that
um the door closes automatically to
the entrance to the alley to keep that
safe
so that residents don't need a key they
just need a fob to get in and out and
then the door closes automatically
behind them
and
we could also put a condition about the
windows
on the top story
um this is the first time I've I've been
on planning committee where someone's
coming and saying I want to build
lifetime homes
and that is so important
as I've said before we had to move from
our wonderful Edwardian house because
we couldn't adapt it to meet my
disability needs instead we've moved to
a bungalow
these are houses that somebody could
live in
no matter what because they could be
adapted and
and I think that's fantastic so I think
we should approve the application and I
propose that what a provenator current
format
with conditions with specifically
about the gates and about the windows on
the top story
[Music]
okay
just doing some technical checking on
that proposal did you speak Council
speaking
um yeah I have to say I'm running to
agree with uh councilor Proctor under
councilor Kevin Proctor uh I think are
on balance the the development of five
family homes on Brownfield sites
so close to a town center is is really
attractive I do think within the
constraints of the site it's I don't
know what more could be done in terms of
um distances and boundaries
um
that would enable development to come
forward I think it's a I think it's an
attractive proposition
so that was that a second The Proposal
from Council Proctor to improve with
conditions uh yeah yeah if that's
possible it's possible
to secondary yes um
specific conditions yeah officers do
have some concerns about not the um not
the fob lock on uh councilor but the one
about obscure glazing because that would
mean that bedrooms the only Outlook from
a bedroom would be obscure glazed and we
wouldn't consider that to have a
appropriate
um level of immunity for the occupants
of that bedroom you would want a clear
glazed a clear glazed window
um
I think it's worth saying that officers
do think that there could be a
Development coming forward on this site
but not five
yeah yeah but you know if if you if you
provided
um fewer properties on there
um you could have side parking you
wouldn't need to have the alley you
could
um you could reorientate them so the
overlooking issues were were you could
have dual aspects so you could obscure
so so I I think officers advice is
if members do want to see development
Conformity on this site the thing is to
do is to refuse this put Market down and
it comes back with something which
addresses all the issues that you've
heard this evening thank you
councilor Eckersley
um I'd just like to say I agree
completely um with the officers I think
it does feel like it's a little bit of
over development
um and I would be concerned with the
height of the the properties as well
when you look at those on either side in
addition to that I have concerns around
the um the second floor the roof space
and the
um and I agree with the concerns of
residents about the overlooking with
that as well so I'll be um against this
as well thank you councilor councilor
Baba
thank you chair
um you know given the fact the the needs
for new homes in Trafford and you know
looking at the plans I'm sure you know
developer can consider all the
recommendations or the opinions and this
is something you know which can be
revised or you know we should consider
it with conditions I'm sure you know we
can achieve an amicable resolution on
this
yeah it very much depends on how many
conditions we want to put on an
application before because before it
becomes not the application which is
which is which is in front of us but
yeah and that was a gen that's a general
Point really Council of Alton yeah I
think we I really like this scheme
actually and I I like the way it looks I
like the materials that it that it uses
um and I think I don't mind the fact at
all that it you know that it's different
from the other houses on the street
because you know we're going to have to
build more houses like this if we you
know if we if we're going to combat the
climate emergency basically that's it
it's a it's a fact we're going to need
to use more of these materials so more
houses are going to end up looking like
this so streets are going to change
um a bit
I think
I'm happy that there's a sound planning
reason for for turning this this down
and then hoping that the developer will
come back with that you know with with
maybe a slightly scaled down proposal
um I had I was my big idea was to to
that that we that becomes a full a full
property development and then everyone
can park down the side and then you can
all have a nice front garden wouldn't
that be lovely
um but uh but you know but but that's
not what what's in front of us is it
it's not I know I I know but I think you
know that's that's a possibility as as
is the side parking um issue we've got
good reason to turn it down hopefully it
will come back to us before very long
um and therefore I will happily um
support the officer's recommendation to
refuse even though I really love it in
loads of ways
thank you counselor thank you
so we've got super bells in front of us
the first one we'll have to take the one
which goes against officer
recommendation first so the proposal
from councilor Proctor seconded by
Council Deacon is to approve against
officer recommendation with two
conditions one around a key fob one
about around glazed windows on the
and just in case it carries and other
conditions as to be established by
officers because you wouldn't just have
those two conditions on it you would
need to defer and delegate the rest of
them to officers absolutely right better
still
so all those in favor of
that
um motion to approve in line with to
approve against opposite recommendations
with conditions to be delegated to
officers so all those in favor of the
show
all those against
make that six
then I will cast my boat in the same way
I cast the first boat which is against
officer recommendation with conditions
then that is approved with
um
approved because it couldn't approved
conditions to be deferred and delegated
to officers mindful of the comments made
by councilor Proctor okay exactly yes
I thought
okay the next item is
the next item is
if we could if we could if we could
focus members
we're bigger Focus members
the next item is
land to the east of
Warwick Warwick Road South uh page 144
of the Pack Mr Pearson to give an
introduction
sorry
councilor pointed out that there were
six
five four
I had the casting vote for the avoidance
okay for the points of doubt we'll do
the votes again does it make sense okay
so the motion is to approve to approve
against officer recommendation with
delegated powers for the officers to
work out the agreement to work out an
agreement between uh to work out some
petitions in line with what council
Proctor said so all those in favor of
that to show
all those against
six six
hours the chair I get a casting vote
so I vote in line with the first way I
voted which to approve against officer
recommendation with delegated powers so
it's seven six
okay
thank you
so to repeat the next item on the agenda
is land to the east of Warwick Road
South and old traffords on page 14144 at
the park Mr Pearson is going to do the
introduction
once the technology works
Mr Pearson yeah thank you chairman sorry
about that delay with the screen
okay the the supplication
um site is located on the east side of
Warwick Road South Old Trafford
comprises
um with the
so you can see the uh the drawings uh
series of single story and one two-story
building previously in industrial
storage and Veterinary surgery use
um
the application seeks full planning
permission for the erection of three
residential buildings providing 80
affordable apartments following the
demolition of all buildings on site
the development comprises a one five
story Block located on the corner of
Warwick Road uh South and airs Road and
two four-story blocks along Warwick Road
South
it's a site layer
um 22 parking spaces to the rear of the
building it's a proposed and Associated
Landscaping
all apartments will be affordable with
23 units for shared ownership and 57 for
social rent
they will be delivered by Southway
Housing Trust
just run through the rest of the slides
for you thus the Landscaping plan
um you can see that the buildings have
been set away from the uh the boundary
with the allotments there some
elevational drawings of block a on Block
B
Street Scene drawings and some visuals
that's the corner block
the junction of ours Road and Mark Road
South
and then driving us from visuals I
should say from from Warwick Road South
that's the rear of the site where it
joins the allotments and there's the
front of the building again
objections have been received from 13
neighboring properties and allotment
holders
the main concerns raised relating to the
impacts of the proposed development on
the adjacent allotments insufficient car
parking impacts on residential amenity
and impacts on nesting birds and other
Wildlife on the allotment site
the principle of residential development
on this Brownfield site in a highly
sustainable location is considered to be
acceptable
substantial weight is afforded to the
contribution of the scheme would make
towards the council's housing land
Supply
the buildings are considered to be of an
appropriate scale and height for the
location where predominantly two and
three still the story development to the
east and south meets the Metrolink stock
cricket ground and larger scale
proposals in the Civic quarter
the articulation detailing proposed
materials are considered to result in a
well-designed scheme albeit with minor
harm to the setting of non-designated
Heritage assets on assets Road
sorry Android all apartments meet ndss
standards and each department has its
own private amenity space
the applicant has demonstrated that the
proposed buildings would not result in a
loss of sunlight or daylight to the
adjacent allotments over the growing
Seasons as a whole when compared to the
existing situation
it's considered accessible in terms of
Highway and parking impacts the level of
car parking is below the council's
maximum standards but considered
acceptable having regard to the highly
sustainable location
evidence provided in the submitted
transport statement also demonstrates
the availability of on-street parking
spaces nearby the local Highway
Authority has not raised an objection to
The Proposal
any harm to biodiversity and
specifically to nesting Birds present on
the allotment site can be avoided by
conditions and the greater Manchester
ecology unit have not raised any
objections in that regard
all of the detail matters have been
assessed and the proposal is considered
to be acceptable
Financial contributions towards the
provision of open space clay facilities
and sports facilities would be secured
by section 106 agreement
and a condition would secure the
development for a 100 affordable housing
the additional information report refers
to the impact of noise from surrounding
land uses on the amenity of future
residents
it concludes that an acceptable internal
living environment can be delivered
taking into account the noise from
Emirates old traffic cricket ground
nearby businesses and noise and
vibration from the Metrolink line and
Depot
a number of additional conditions and
revisions to conditions in the main
report are also recommended
the Tilted balance in the mppf paragraph
11d is engaged and it's considered that
the benefits of the scheme will
significantly demonstrably outweigh the
harm which would arise applications
therefore recommended for approval
subject to appropriate conditions and a
legal agreement
thank you thank you Mr Pearson is do we
have Miss Scott and councilor Lloyd
Richard care to go first
again you press the microphone you get
three minutes once you press the button
to speak
thank you Mr Scott
foreign
[Music]
feel free to start again okay thank you
okay I just so if you missed it I'm Dr
Nicholas Scott I'm a resident of
Manchester for 22 years an Old Trafford
resident for six years and a Seymour
Grove plot holder for 11. I'm opposing
this from the perspective of allotment
plot holders and residents who've also
submitted objections not because we're
opposed to Flats we're not we want new
builds we want affordable housing that's
appropriate for this area
um but this proposal in its current
state does not meet those needs
okay we welcome also the changes
suggested by the PBA the developers to
create a boundary between the blocks and
the allotments that's great however
they're key there are key problems that
remain
in relation to affordable housing when
you look more closely at what is written
the planning submissions show that only
23 of the proposed 80 flats or 28 28.75
will be affordable in perpetuity which
is under the council's affordable
housing policy of 40 percent
it's clear that this area needs
long-term affordable housing not flats
that in likelihood will become airbnbs
for the nearby sporting stadia fixtures
also the blocks of flats are four to
five stories are not in keeping with
current housing
which consists of most of three blocks
of three-story Flats which we're totally
fine with and that borders our
perimeters we're not against these Flats
at all they just need to be three
stories and the rest of the housing in
the area is only two stories high
as an experienced plot holder and Urban
Farmer
I must say that uh the yeah the height
of these Flats will negatively affect
cultivation on the allotment
or Secretary of the allotments has
informed me that potential plot holders
shown the sites that will be affected by
these bills
um they don't want to take these parts
once they know about what will be there
and the effect the negative effect on
the daylight we have a six year waiting
list so access to productive plots are
needed within a cost of living crisis
and food security crisis
the proposed Heights of the buildings
have allowed will also set a really
dangerous precedent for future planned
housing along the Ayers Road and its
adjacent perimeter of our site it's in
this context to remind you that
according to traffic council's strategic
planning osr5 policy our allotment is
designated as a protected Green Space
that has existed there for over 100
years we're a Community Asset as
evidenced by our open days you know we
get everyone from the local area there
buildings of 45 stories high on the
perimeter
uh just make those plots nearby really
unproductive and unusable this also
negatively impacts biodiversity reliant
on forage as well as ecosystem Services
now if the council is is really serious
about addressing its climate emergency
these two factors are key to protect
yeah they we survive on them Humanities
wise on ecosystem services and
biodiversity if we screw that up we're
screwed as a race yeah
um and I also just want to point out
that the parking is inadequate there's
22 spaces whilst we'd love to think that
not having parking on site will mean
that the buyers of these Flats will not
have cars that just isn't true you just
have to go to the nearby blocks of flats
built near tram stops to see the amounts
of parking there this reduces active
travel it makes traveling to that area
even more dangerous than it is now
especially on Match days with pavement
parking and dangerous driving
thank you Dr Scott
Council Lloyd
you of course will be allowed five
minutes to speak once you once you press
the button thank you that's already on
um
I'm speaking not actually
um against the development because we do
need housing and Trafford it is on the
Brownfield site but some of the aspects
that have already been raised I would
just like to reiterate
the allotments behind the building are
going to be affected and my colleague
colleagues and I have visited the
allotment and we've had conversations
with the plot holders
we support the allotment holders given
that they've been there for some
considerable time
and one of those is one of those plot
holders it is concerned that the
planning report
misrepresents concerns she raised about
the president that this staff
development called fat
if approved in terms of scale Heights
Etc while the resubmitted application
has moved the buildings away from the
boundary one block is proposed to be
five stories
um we have further two further sites of
our site which is designated as
protected green spaces and approval of
this with a five-story block threatens
more of the plots in terms of being
suitable for food growing due to
overshadowing the plots
the report on page 153 says that
objections were made about compromising
protected Green Space in this part of
Old Trafford
what she said was specific to the
derelict buildings which are right for a
Redevelopment surrounding two sides of
this site and the development creating a
precedence on the height
um like at the issue of parking
you've already said that it's less in
this development there is off street
parking I agree but it is in use
constantly in the day on Warwick Road
South from Saint Hilda's church so it's
quite a way from there
we've heard complaints of double parking
during the day we've also had complaints
about parking on airs Road from the
mosque situated there because there's an
awful lot of parking out there there are
parking for business and but some of
it's for people who are compute
commuters and they Park their vehicles
on theirs Road and use the tram
on Fridays attendance of the mosque also
increases car parking and it is
particularly bitty with again more
representation to us from residents
so yes those 22 car parking same faces
seem to be too few and that is referred
to a new part it would be better if
there were more on-site parking so it
wouldn't increase the car parking in
what is already a very very congested
area and
um thank you for listening
thank you councilor
there's Mr Flanagan president
[Music]
microphone for your three minutes thank
you Mr Flanagan
good evening commissee my name is Tom
Flanagan of Paul Butler Associates we're
the planning consultants for this
application there are just a few points
I'd like to make
the applicant has been working closely
with the council and local community on
this project for a period of three years
with this being the second planning
applications to be progressed
during this period there have been
significant changes to the scheme these
include a reduction in the number of
apartments from 126 to 80. for the
schemes to comprise 100 affordable
housing
I reduce Footprints and repositioning of
the buildings to ensure no adverse
impacts on the allotments an increase in
car parking provision and soft
landscaping and for all apartments to be
provided with privacy immunity space as
well as communal space
due to this close collaboration there
have been no objections to the scheme
from statutory consultees whilst various
Council departments including how
including housing strategy and growth
the local highways Authority and
pollution and housing have confirmed
their support for the proposals
we appreciate that some concerns have
been raised by allotment holders and
residents however their concerns have
been addressed through design changes
and additional updated reporting in
support of the application
the development will provide HC
dwellings the size and type of
accommodation will provide high quality
housing that will appeal to a range of
households thereby contributing to a
sustainable community
the scheme will help address a shortage
of Housing and an identified need for
good quality affordable housing in the
borough
in addition the scheme will provide a
series of planning and regeneration
benefits these include
redevelopments of a Brownfield site that
comprises a series of vacant and
uncyclable unsightly buildings
improvements to the appearance of the
science and contribution to the
Regeneration of the surrounding area
including the adjacent Civic quarter
the delivery of high quality design
scheme that will provide active Frontage
to Warwick Rose South and airs Road
enhancing activity and natural
surveillance
provision of economic benefits from
construction and expenditure in the
local community as well as social
impacts and sustainability benefits due
to the scheme being progressed by McGuff
construction a developer basing Trafford
that employs local people
and finally the scheme will bring a
number of environmental benefits through
the efficient use of land the site being
in a highly accessible sustainable
location adjacent to Trafford trans stop
incorporating tree planting and green
infrastructure resourcing in
biodiversity in that game
the provision of 100 Cycle parking an
electric vehicle charging points
in summary the proposals are in
accordance with national and local
planning policy have the support of
statutory Council fees and Council
offices and will bring significant
benefits for the people of Trafford
thank you
thank you Mr Flanigan
before I ask members to speak I just
asked for a contribution from the
highways officer about the the points
raised about parking in highways
generally
okay so with regards to the parking
um it's been pointed out that the site
is very close to the Civic quarter and
had the development been proposed for
the Civic quarter they would actually
have required a maximum of 16 parking
spaces
they're proposing 28 parking for this
one
we have had two parking surveys
undertaken by the Developers
the first parking survey used
um more relaxed standards and showed a
maximum of 53 of the available on-street
parking was used
the second parking survey which
specified that they could only count
spaces where there was no parking on the
footway where there was no parking near
the Junctions where there were no
accesses obscured in any way
um that showed a maximum of 71 of
available parking was in use now for
residence parking and for Resident
surveys the surveys are undertaken
between half past midnight and 5 30 in
the morning which is the period when
most residents will be at home
so the parking surveys have actually
demonstrated that there is capacity
within the highway for overflow parking
it's in a highly sustainable area
and as I say it is also very close to
the Civic quarter car ownership levels
for the area also show that in single
person households 58 own no car
in two-person households with no
dependents fifteen percent have no car
and fifty percent have one car
so and that takes doesn't take into
account the fact that when it's
apartments and flats car ownership
levels are usually lower than that
so from the highways point of view we're
um happy to accept a lower provision we
feel that it's been demonstrated that
there won't be a severe impact to the
highway in terms of the mppf
okay thank you uh Mr Pearson I know it's
dealt with quite extensively in the
report but given the concerns of the
allotment holders could just have just a
few words on the um the impact of this
of The Proposal on the developments yes
sure thank you thank you chairman yes I
mean certainly when this application
um came in after a previous application
had been withdrawn officers officers had
expressed some concern about the
proximity of that development to to the
allotments and so the applicants
um
um had a consultant look into the the
impacts of overshadowing on the
allotments and that concluded on that
previous scheme it will be a significant
adverse impact on the allotments which
we were most concerned about that said
the scheme has been revised as fresh
application is now in and and the
buildings have been moved away from the
boundary with the allotments and the
conclusion of that study into how the
the buildings and the overshadowing will
impact on the allotments is is quite
clear in that it's saying that there's
going to be if anything is going to be a
positive impact in that because the
buildings have moved away
um overall across the growing season
when you take in into it into account
the the plots as a whole it'll be an
improved situation compared to the
existing
um there's that includes a sunlight
comparison report which suggests that
the first Shadow when the allotment is
in 50 Shadow and 100 shadow
um those times will be later in the day
on the when these new buildings go up
then they will be at present when they
with the existing buildings sat on on
the boundary
um
I mean we we don't think there's going
to be any harm we we consulted the
national allotment Society who objected
to the previous application they've not
raised any concerns in relation to this
they haven't responded actually but
they've not raised any objection uh and
moreover we've not had ever any evidence
to suggest that there will be any
overshadowing of the allotments
um
and on top of that we're talking now
that the suggestion is that that only 10
out of 116 allotments on that site will
be the subjective of any impact
um and for officers I think we feel it's
reasonable to include even if there had
been even if that report had concluded
there would have been some adverse
impact it wouldn't have changed our
recommendation on the overall planning
balance
um so I hope that's that covers those
issues chairman okay thank you Mr person
any member wishing to speak Council
Proctor
thank you chair I've it's I don't want
to
speak on it I want to ask questions of
the traffic officers thank you
so your traffic survey was between
midnight and 5 A.M
was any traffic surveys done when there
are football matches cricket matches or
other events at either of those two
premises or when masjids were having
Services thanks
no because
um as I say when it's a residence
parking you look at parking in the
evening rather than parking during the
day which is usually done when you do
the survey for a business
um or commercial use that's normally
done during the day
um I would add that the occupiers of
these Flats would not be entitled to
permits for the parking scheme that's
there so there there's no automatic
entitlement to those permits there will
also be a condition for a robust travel
plan where they'll have to demonstrate a
modal shift to more active methods of
travel public transport and such like
the flats are also going to be marketed
with little to no parking so people will
know before they move in what they're
getting into so to speak
and then I have a further question
you said
um on the research of the percentage of
car ownership for people in
two-bedroomed
um something like 15 don't have a car 50
have one car so does that mean that 35
have two or more cars
it does but the it takes into
consideration all types of housing it
doesn't differentiate between houses
um and apartments flats that type of
thing and it's there's evidence to
suggest that people who live in houses
in sorry flats or apartments actually
have a lower level of car ownership
um recent census data which has just
been published suggests that certainly
for some areas car ownership levels have
decreased
thank you and then I have a question for
officers other officers
are there any accessible parking spaces
in this plan please
Council there are let's double check I
think there are four
yeah four accessible spaces yeah thank
you
any other member wish to speak
Council Walton
right there's a lot to like about this
scheme the affordable element it's
accessible it's energy efficient and
there's a generation a power generation
element and it promises to bring greater
biodiversity to the site than as they're
currently the units are of an acceptable
size and the design is is pretty nice as
well so it's great I understand the
concerns of the allotment holders
regarding the proximity and height but
I'm reassured by the fact that the
buildings are set back
um and they are and also the location to
the west of the allotments um so I agree
that the shading won't be an issue and I
think probably the precedent won't be an
issue because we we deal each with each
planning application on its merits is
that correct so if one is another
development is shading the allotments
then that will become a much greater
concern
um and we'll consider that when it um
when it arises
um now I'm I'm really in favor of you
know of of having few car parking spaces
where where we've got a um a development
you know like this in a very sustainable
location
I am really concerned though that we've
gone against the
tfgm's recommendation to um you know to
have a a review
um to look into it for a tro a traffic
regulation order in this area because
the potential is that it is going to
bring a lot of cars onto the street and
that is going to affect the residential
immunity of the people living alongside
we're basically saying oh it's
absolutely fine to have lots of parked
cars parked on the street some of them
parked on the pavement and that kind of
thing and that is going to change the
street scene
um for you know um for sure when you're
dealing with this low number of of car
parking spaces for that many flats then
it's a concern and I think we should be
brave and we should be bold in this case
in this situation and put that condition
in there okay the council can do it
anyway and hopefully the councilors will
work we'll work on that but I would like
really like us here today to approve
this but with the condition that we
should have a review Into the the review
Into the tro that that tfgm recommend
recommends
and that will and if it does recommend a
tro then that will protect the street
from you know from from parking and it
will give extra discouragement from
people who are buying these flats from
having a you know from from owning a car
in the first place because they'll know
they won't be out it will be difficult
to park it in the local area
that's my view thank you thank you
councilor before I speak to anybody else
wants to speak
oh councilmanis
I'll say I'm incomplete
um I think that with that condition I
would be then happy to propose it
because I think again I think I like the
development
um I think that there's a lot going for
it I think
um and it's in a sustainable location I
think it's the right the right sort of
development that we need those extra
um conditions
so thank you
okay with regards
request for the tro that would require a
section 106 contribution from the
developer
um so it need to be determined if that
contribution meets the test under the
mppf
I think I think certainly on some of the
other larger developments we've seen in
the vicinity in the Civic Causeway I
think including the the Kellogg site
um
certainly there was a requirement for
because of the some concerns I expressed
about parking there there was a
suggestion that I think it was a
condition
um that required a review of car parking
in in the area and if it could be over a
period of time and if it could be
demonstrated that there was a level of
on-street car parking that was causing
harm and that harm could be attributed
attributed to the residents of that
scheme then we should look at the
potential for for introduction for tro
um so I mean if committee are concerned
about it we we could always seek to add
a condition along those lines so that's
to do a survey as opposed to making a
subject 106 agreements certainly from
memory on on the catalog site there was
a requirement for the developer to over
a period of time to that would be agreed
with the highway authority to do a
number of surveys to to look into how
the parking was was was working out I'm
just saying if and if it was if it could
be demonstrated that any
um on-street parking was at such a level
it was causing a problem to amenity of
existing neighbors and that harm could
be attributed to cars associated with
that development then the developer
would be required to I think yeah fund
those tros yes that's right it was the
based on the number of complaints
received within a certain period of time
and it had to be proven that the parking
in question was directly associated with
the Kellogg's developments and that
could be done as part of a condition as
opposed to going down the whole section
yeah it would be a parking management
strategy
um however if it was found that there
was a problem and a tro was needed then
there would need to be some form of
commitment from the applicant that they
would fulfill as it were all costs
associated with that would be for them
to pay it to have to be a neutral cost
too but we can delegate the details of
that to yeah I'll do that okay so the
proposal is in line with
um what you said councilor Welton which
is the the
um scheme as it stands but conditioned
with um the details we worked out around
the impact of this on traffic
any other member wish to speak Council
Proctor thank you chair I think it's too
big
it's too high and yes 10 allotment plots
doesn't sound a massive amount but it's
almost 10 percent of the allotments will
be affected there's 116 allotments and
10 of them
are going to be affected it's nearly 10
percent
of the allotment site so it's not oh
it's only 10 it's actually
10 percent
and it's it's too big and I'd object to
it on grounds of massing certainly the
five stories
is way too big I'd be much happier with
three stories fewer Flats
fewer Vehicles needing to park
I just think it's it's too big for the
site and it is
it's surrounded by buildings that are
a couple of floors lower
and so I I would
um I won't I'll be voting against
okay thank you councilor counteracting
um well I'm very supportive of this I
think uh clearly we need the affordable
housing and accommodations and and this
fits a bill as far as I'm concerned I
think I I was concerned about the
allotments but I've been reassured by
the officers and the work that had
actually been done that
um I think
it's not a material problem now uh that
it first was in the in the first uh
initiation of the plans so I I think
they've done a good job in terms of that
so I'm quite happy to support
um the
um the recommendations okay thank you
councilor Council Baba
yeah thank you
um based on the fact that you know this
has come back again with a reduction in
the number of Apartments I'll be
supporting
um you know the proposal especially
after you know hearing from the officer
here in terms of the traffic measures
and you know the numbers we've got I
think it is manageable and always
supportive of it thank you councilor uh
Mr Pierce we're just like to clarify
something thank you thank you chairman
just going back to the tro issue I mean
I made reference to the Kellogg site I
may have got that wrong but certainly
there have been one or two developments
in this general area where we've we've
used the kind of mechanism that we've
described so that was the first point
the second was if it can be delegated to
officers to consider whether that should
be covered by either an additional
clause in the 106 or an additional
condition if committee are happy to to
delegate that point to officers thank
you
councilman
I'm not certain if I've actually
officially proposed oh I made a note
that you had I had okay okay
so the proposal is to accept the
agreement as it stands but with a
delegated
um some work for the officers delegating
around parking and highways
so all those in favor sure
nine all those against
one against
okay so that's uh proposal is carried
thank you
the next item is eight Kings Road it's
on page two two six of your pack and uh
Miss Milner will give the introduction
[Music]
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry Dr Scott
Dr Scott the way the committee Works no
Dr Scott you you've had you've had your
contribution
you've had your contribution I'd be very
grateful if you leave the room thank you
thank you Dr Scott Dr Scott please
Dr Scott
thank you Dr Scott thank you
Ms Milner
thank you chair
the next application seeks permission to
vary the approved application from 2019
for the direction of a new dwelling
house within the side Garden of number
eight Kings Road in sale
um the amendments are for increase in
scale height width depth at the first
floor alterations to the ground floor
footprint sighting include part
reductions and alterations to window
positions and alterations to landscaping
and
for those of you that have visited the
site the main structure of the dwelling
has already been constructed with block
work walls and Timber Frame restructure
in place facing brickwork has largely
been installed to the front sides and
rear at ground floor and aluminum frame
Windows have been installed with some
openings the proposed Timber cladding
um for the first and second floors
um and the roof towels have yet to be
installed or formally agreed by officers
objections
um receive consider that the change the
approved scheme would have an
unacceptable impact on the character of
the street scene with the property
appearing
overbearing and disproportionate within
the plot there is concerns about the
impact on the quality of the proposal
and it being inferiorated out of the
approved scheme also the
um concerned about the impact on amenity
and the accuracy and reliability of the
information that has been submitted with
the current application
um
there are changes to this proposal in
regards to the scale of the the property
but also the context and I'll just
quickly show you this so these are the
proposed plans and what you're seeing
here is make sure you can see it on site
is um
as the development has commenced on site
it's become apparent that the original
plans specifically in relation to the
neighboring properties were not accurate
so the scale of the development whilst
it is slightly larger the
context of the street scene is also
different so what you're seeing here I
hope you can see it clearly is a blue
line and a orange line so the orange
line was what the neighboring properties
were measured on the approved scheme and
the blue line is how they've actually
measured up on site so
as you can see again so the the orange
line is of the of the application
property and of the neighboring property
was how it was approved last time but
now on site what you see is the blue
line is the accurate reflection of the
neighboring properties and so what
you're seeing is
the houses slightly larger than approved
but the neighboring properties are lower
in the context
um so that's the current proposal this
is just a an image from the previous
approval
um
but I think it's best to go off the
measurements
so we are um and this is the the
property like I said if you've been on
site that there is uh the main blockwork
structure is in place it is proposed
that it would be clad
um at first floor so this is a a clearly
an unfinished structure and within the
street scene and so officers are kind of
looking at the scheme and saying is it
is it still acceptable is the scale of
the proposal acceptable is it acceptable
when the the
um the context to which we now know is
more accurate
um
we have been on site we have assessed it
we've verified some of the measurements
and we are accepting that it is a larger
proposal than than originally um
expected however being mindful of the
previous permission and being mindful
that the Contemporary
um design solution was supported last
time
um we are not raising issues in respect
of the architectural treatment of The
Proposal and given the changes to the
massing on balance are considered to be
minor although they are notable we do
consider that on balance we would still
recommend approval and noting the
conditions within the officer reports
the committee report there are a few
changes to the um previous conditions
most notably permitted development
rights so previously we didn't remove
rights regarding federal extensions to
the building we now feel it is necessary
that no further extensions and
alterations could take place to this
building to this property sorry if
approved
um and that's this without further
planning permission
um but other than that we are proposing
approval thank you chair
uh thank you Miss Milner um is either Mr
Brady or councilor Gilbert's presence
okay whichever one of you wishes to go
first
and Mr Brady you'll get three minutes
once you press the microphone and start
speaking thank you
people
we're grateful for site of the planning
officers report dated fitter June and
note the recommendation that the
application be granted
however the report of February 19
observed that through the life of the
application Amendments have been secured
to reduce the height of the roof to
align with the neighboring properties of
numbers 8 and 12. and concluded that the
height of the building has been amended
to provide a natural increase along the
road
it was because of this restriction that
the proposed high for the building was
considered acceptable
references made in the most recent
report to the perceived increase in
scale above the original approved plans
there is nothing perceived about the
increase in scale it is real
any suggestion that the height of number
10 as it now stands is not problematic
because other houses nearby are as tall
if not taller than number 10. undermines
the original officers assessment that
there should be a natural increase in
Heights along the road
whatever the measured survey hikes and
approved design Heights may be as
Illustrated in the height comparison
Street Scene document and whatever
errors there may have been in the
original plans the purpose of the
original approved proposal was to create
a harmonious Continuum of height from 8
to 12 irrespective of the design of the
buildings the reality is seen in the
photograph provided on the 27th of April
of this year unequivocally shows the
difference between what exists now and
what was intended and approved
what was intended and what now exists in
terms of scale bear no relation to each
other the impact of the differences is
not minor or slight this applies to the
width as well as the height of the build
the net result is that the build is
overbearing and out of place
there has been a previous infraction of
the approved plans when the initial
footings laid exceeded the boundary and
had to be removed and relayed even with
the adjustment to the footings the build
fails to conform to the approved
distances from 8 and 12. but the Gia has
been reduced by an insignificant 113
square feet at the rear of the property
there's nothing to address the massing
issues presented at the front which are
aggravated by the changes to the wall
facing number eight
in failing to adhere to that which was
permitted this but a complaint about
design but mass and size
if this retrospective application is
successful it would render the previous
deliberation of this matter otos and the
consideration given to the many
unthoughtful conditions imposed
meaningless in particular the desire to
an agreeable gradation in hype between 8
and 12. it is not just a matter of
height however for the increase in
height now renders what was an
acceptably prominent Frank Gable to be
overly prominent and unduly dominant
the committee is respectfully invited to
reject the application and require Mr
Durbin a very experienced developer to
adhere to the original scheme thank you
thank you
Council Gilbert if you would
you will get five minutes from now when
you press the microphone thank you
can you hear me
um I'd like to thank the committee for
their time on what's a very busy agenda
and I have noted the recommendation to a
grant and knowing that you would need a
clear reason for going against the
officers I believe we have that reason
or reasons plural King's Road is one of
the many attractive roads in
astronomersie Ward with a mix of housing
not All Uniform but blending in
harmoniously and I hope that many as
many of the committee members here as
possible have had the opportunity to go
and visit the road prior to tonight's
meeting
on visiting you will see that this
development is clearly out of kilter
with the rest of the properties and the
impact on the street scene is too great
this is with height and width and the
imposing style and this is directly at
odds with our design code that
developments must enhance the Street
theme this does not
I also hope you've had the opportunity
to read some of the thoughtful and
reasonable objections from local
residents these are summarized briefly
in the report and have been articulated
well by Mike but in the interest of
expediency I would ask the committee to
consider these key facts the initial
application in 2019 was amended to bring
the height in line with the natural line
across the road and as stated previously
it has since transpired that the heights
of the neighboring properties were
submitted by the architect and developer
were incorrect these houses were in fact
lower and this makes the height
difference much more obvious the
resubmitted Heights you have from the
10th of June are accurate and they have
been validated by the planning team and
they do reflect a small dip in ground
level at number 10. nonetheless this
does not take away from the fact that
the property is indisputably
significantly higher than additionally
initially agreed
a resident who's much better at maths
than I am has calculated has given me
some very detailed calculations which
I'm happy to share but um he's
calculated that an overall seven percent
increase in height
um is being recommended to be granted
now in my day job when we're looking at
margins of error with data seven percent
would be unacceptable I appreciate that
the law allows retrospective changes and
this can be really useful when things go
on go wrong however approving a
retrospective increase goes against
these initial conditions the roof space
is clearly divided into rooms and we
cannot dispute that an approval would
enable the original and rejected
three-story building plans by stealth I
appreciate the supply of housing is very
important in Trafford and we must have
policies regarding this I just don't
think they're relevant in this case this
is a plot in a much sought after
um area and it will have a home on it
the question is is that house suitable
and appropriate and moreover respectful
of the initial planning permission
granted and the nearby neighbors so with
the height and the cladding and the
increased math of the property and its
contemporary style upright roof odds
with the neighboring period properties
and all round scope creep I believe the
committee does have reasonable grounds
to refuse this retrospective request
please refuse and stick to the original
plans and conditions which were to quote
a resident the best of the worst but a
reasonable compromise for all parties
thank you
thank you councilor
is Mr Atkinson in the public area
first microphone
thank you and you will get three minutes
to speak thank you Ms Robinson
the permission that is being applied for
is solely for the amendment to the
drawings in condition number two of the
approved application
the principle of the Gable fronted black
cloud dwelling with an asymmetric roof
and contemporary fenestration has
already been approved and deemed
suitable by Trafford Council any
discussions regarding anything other
than the minor height change into the
approved approved plans should be
discounted
throughout the application process we
have worked tirelessly with the planning
department at Trafford to only present
the facts on the previously approved
plans the drawings show the houses on
eight Kings Road to be 500 mil higher on
the 12 Kings Road to be 800 mil higher
this made the approved dwelling appear
smaller the main point of the objection
letter is that the building is higher
than the neighboring Eaves and ridge
this would still have been the case even
if the building would have been built in
exactly in accordance with the approved
plans
as the contextual elevation heights were
incorrect on the application submitted
by the previous applicant we have had an
independent digital survey undertaken
this has also been confirmed by the
planning officers
it's also in the committee report the
officer report covers the majority of
the points I would like to make so I'd
like to reiterate the main items the
increase in effective Ridge height and
ease level is considered minor in the
context of the approved plans and is not
considered excessive
the front Gable is prominent however
fronted Gable form has already been
approved it is not considered to be
overly prominent or unduly dominant in
the street scene compared to the
approved elevation
the height of the properties do range
and it is observed that the terrorist
opposite is notably higher than its
neighbors number 11 and 13 and
significantly more so than the
difference in height between the
application property and its neighbors
either side number 8 and 12. the
difference in Ease on number eight is
noticeable but not considered excessive
overall the dwelling is considered to
provide satisfactory design and would
appropriately address scale density
massing and layout in conclusion The
Proposal would not result in material
harm to living conditions of the
occupiers of the neighboring Properties
or future occupiers and it is considered
to be compliant with core strategies L7
the nppf and spg1 the scheme complies
with a development plan and when taken
as a whole the increasing scale is minor
in the context of the scheme and the
scheme is not significantly different
from the approval and the principle of
this contemporary dwelling including
General scale form and sighting has
already been granted
there is not considered to be a
significant or unreasonable immunity
impact on neighboring dwellings from The
Proposal finally it isn't it is
considered that there are no adverse
impacts of granting permission that will
significantly or demonstrably outweigh
the benefits When assessed against the
policies in this framework taken as a
whole is therefore recommended that the
planning permission be approved this
house is not for a degree developer it's
for a family home a forever home like a
few times
uh thank you Mr Atkinson does any member
wish to speak
Council minutes
it's awkward isn't it because
the height is
um obviously a little bit higher and the
neighboring properties were weren't
measured correctly at the first in the
first place however when you look at how
how much higher I think even if we're
given what was approved last that's
already been approved
um even with the corrected roof Heights
of next next doors it's still higher so
you're never going to get that even if
you went to the full back position
you're never going to get the um the
gradual height
um sort of thing you know going
gradually increasing so that that is not
going to happen
um it is a little bit higher um is it
unacceptably higher I've I've given that
we're not going to have the gradual
incline I think that it's not
unacceptably higher and therefore I'm
minded to go with the officer
recommendation because I think that
the fullback is already
something that's going that's not going
to be the gradual thing I don't see
um the that argument is that ship has
sailed effectively the it looking
different to its neighbors that ship has
sailed all those ships have sailed we're
literally on the um it being a little
bit higher than
you know otherwise
um so I think that actually I'm going to
propose that we the grant this
application thank you
Council Proctor thank you chair I I
don't agree with councilman is I recall
um earlier this year we had a house that
had been built not according to its plan
and
um they came with retrospective
planning application and we turned it
down
it wasn't
um Council offices that meant that
measured the buildings too high it was
the architecture team
and right now it's not too late for the
Builder to fix this
and I think
we should make them fix sets we need to
be consistent in our decisions
as regards to retroactive
planning applications and if we're
rejecting one
because it doesn't quite fit the plans
it originally had we need to remember
that and look at the next retroactive
planning application in the same way
they already had planning approval for
one building and and it's not this
building it's similar to this building
but it isn't this building
thanks thank you counselor
yeah
I think I know which one you mean uh
Castle property talk about Marlborough
Road yes that was much more
significantly different than this is and
I but I'll just leave that there
canister Wilton
thank you I'm happy to
um second uh councilman ministers
proposal to Grant this
um the difference between the you know
between the designs is is limited uh
is certainly not severe enough I think
for us to be able to you know to be able
to to
um refuse refuse this I mean I'd love I
I this is definitely the sins of the
piano of the planning department coming
back to haunters because I don't think
this would get through now given what
they were saying at training about
symmetry last week and it makes me feel
slightly seasick looking at it but um uh
I'm not supposed to comment on the that
I think probably but um but yeah in
terms of we're basically looking at
whether the height issue is is a
relevant concern and I think it's not a
significant enough concern so I'm happy
to
um second The Proposal thank you
thank you Council that counts recklessly
um for me yes I I think
um if this was the initial plan
application I'd be minded to go against
because of the design however I think we
all need to be mindful that the
um design has been approved in the past
whether we like that or not and it would
be unfair to judge this um based on
previous decisions made by officers in
the committee
um for me I think the the height is
relatively insignificant and um I'll be
um minded tour to approve this myself
thanks
Lincoln councilor Council Rockton
yeah I mean
I think the simple truth is that
um this will have an unacceptable impact
on the visual immunity the streets see
and that that's clear and and obvious
and I think that would be the reason why
I will not vote for this
are you proposing we use the application
you're proposing we refuse the
application yeah
second it
uh I'll just wait in before we go to the
vote
I just want to ask officers to explain
about the the difference between the
existing
homes and and and the what they're
asking the Builder is asking what is
centimeter difference what is
it's not all about design it is about
the height very quick summary the um the
dimensions in the report the dimensions
are in the pool and they vary kind of
you know kind of 50 60 70 centimeters
but it's not just about the the number
it's about the context so
you've got to look at the the context as
well as the the number so that we're
saying that it's not just the overall
increase in the number of you know the
actual height I think the increase in
height at the ridge level is uh around
50 or 60 centimeters
um but it's also that the fact that
you've got to consider the context of
the properties either side
but the numbers are and there are many
calculations and they are detailed
within the report
okay thank you uh my view on this is
when I went to see the site visit I
looked at what was there and I did not
like it at all but then I looked to what
I'd been already approved and I didn't
like that either
um so and I don't think the difference
between the two is substantial
um and what we're all what only what
we're considering here is the difference
and I don't think the difference is
enough to turn this down so I will be
boating in line with officer
recommendation so we've got two
proposals the first one is to refuse
against officer recommendation all those
in favor of that indicate now please
I'll make that four and all those
against
let's make that seven
foreign
officer recommendation to all those in
favor
eight
we try that again
Sam yeah all those against
and I make that fall thank you so that
we've brought it to approve that in line
with officer recommendation thank you
uh the next item is uh chibo inhale it's
on page 95 of the pack and Miss Coley
will give the introduction thank you
[Music]
thank you
yes
Miss Coley when I gave the introduction
to chibo members if he could attention
this way
thank you chairman um the application
site is located within the Hale station
Conservation area in the conservation
area appraisal and management plan it is
classified as a positive contributor and
a landmark building and forms part of a
key view in the conservation area the
site is within the setting of the grade
two listed Hale station
retrospective planning permission is
sought for the creation of an external
roof Terrace to the front elevation form
an extended dining area of the
restaurant the roof Terrace comprises a
3.44 meter high glaze canopy with steel
framework and 1.1 meter high glass
balustrade which spans the full width of
the building and extends 1.25 meters
beyond the north side elevation
the roof canopy structure has been
decorating the Driftwood style Timber
moss and artificial leaves and flowers
however this decoration is not
development and the proposal should be
assessed assuming that it is not in
place
the application is a revision to an
almost identical application which
members resolve to refuse in November
2022 this was refused on Heritage and
design grounds and the full text of the
reasons for refusal is contained in the
opposite officer report the applicant
has not appealed against the refusal the
only change proposed from the previous
application is the replacement of the
unauthorized aluminum sash windows and
doors at first row level with new
painted timber frame sash windows and
three sets of painted Timber doors
officers do not consider that this minor
change addresses the two previous
reasons for refusal and as the original
Timber Windows have been lost as has
original brickwork Heritage harm still
arises from this element to The Proposal
there is an extent planning permission
for the creation of a roof Terrace above
the single-story roof to the front
extension
front elevation rather the applicant
that application also approved the
replacement of one existing window with
patio doors that would provide access
out onto the Terrace no canopy was
proposed
the development tracks from the
aesthetic and historic significance of
the building and the positive
contribution the site brings to the
conservation area The Proposal would let
result in less than substantial harm in
mppf terms no public benefits have been
identified which would outweigh the harm
to Heritage assets the number of letters
of support is noted but is a fundamental
principle of the planning system that
decisions should not be made on the
basis of the number of representations
received
the application applicant argues that
the development is required to secure
the viability of the existing business
and that should planning permission be
refused the restaurant would have to
close
a planning inspector has already
dismissed this argument in relation to
an appeal made by the same applicant at
the same site but for a different
proposal members should be Vine for that
in planning terms any consideration of
viability should be based on the
viability of the building is a
restaurant or other commercial use not
the applicant's own business model the
applicant has confirmed that he purchase
the premises
knowing that the roof Terrace was
required to make the business viable
members must satisfy themselves that
another business could not reasonably
operate successfully from the premises
if this application were to be refused
equally should the business close
subsequent harm arising from a vacant
unit should be assessed in terms of its
impact on the vitality and viability of
hail District Center as a whole
this application fails to overcome the
two previous reasons for refusal
proposal is contrary to the development
plan and the relevant Conservation Area
appraisal and management plan the
application of policies in the mppf that
protect areas or assets of particular
importance provide a clear reason for
refusing the development proposed it's
therefore recommended that the
application is refused thank you uh
thank you Miss Coley uh councilor
Spencer and councilor Sutton if you
decide who's going to speak
okay thank you thank you uh is uh Mr
Shannon going to speak as well
whichever one of your cares to speak
first approach the microphone
[Music]
thank you Mr Shani for what we've
watched the drill all evening he will
get three minutes when you when you
press when you press the button
shut up
okay thank you thank you Mr Sharma
apologies
off you go
dear chair and members
I have been a resident of hail and
Bowden for almost 40 years and I'm
speaking as a representative of the
significant number of residents of Hell
who support this proposal I'd like to
start by commenting that 200
representations of support from local
residents have been received for this
application and the previous one and
there have been numerous representations
from residence groups in local media
This is highly unusual given public
interest in applications tends to be
where there is an issue with a proposal
which is not the case here I mentioned
this because I am told by officers that
our views are not considerations that
we're in favor of the grant of
permission I stress that not only is
there significant public support for the
application but all our representations
have raised valid planning grounds which
should be supported as a resident of
hail I live 400 yards from Tebow I walk
past it four times a day visiting
various places in the locality like the
significant number of residents that
support the application I consider that
the proposal has a positive impact on
the appearance of and our enjoyment of
the conservation area and is of a high
quality design we also consider that it
adds vibrancy and interest to the street
scene supports and enhance the vibility
of our Village Center supports
sustainable local employment and
provides an invaluable facility that is
well used by the hail and wider Trafford
community
your officer report tells us that it
doesn't consider the Village Center to
be suffering as residents to use and
engage with local businesses we think we
are well placed to know that it is there
has been a 50 percent increase in
vacancies in the center alone since the
application was submitted and This is 40
percent higher than at any other survey
over the past 20 years chibo is the duel
in the hospitality trade for this
Village it is the principal Hospitality
location in hell as confirmed by an
independent survey the council has
submitted the loss of Cheapo which would
happen if this application is refused
will be catastrophic to the Village
Center and will substantially reduce its
vitality
in conflict with the council strategic
planning policies we are unsure why the
council will want to see such an
important business in the village cease
to trade it's a small size Enterprise
it's headquartered at this restaurant
and its employees almost 70 local people
that will all lose their jobs and whose
families along with other residents
consider the proposal to be exactly what
they want in their Village Center
I appreciate that it is not ideal to be
considering this application
retrospectively but that is not what we
should be looking at here it is our
enjoyment of the conservation area and
Village Center that will be negatively
impacted by a refusal of the application
and which could lead to an appeal that
we do not want and I don't think that
the council or Representatives do either
we would like to leave members with
these final points the application is
one that can residents consider is well
designed and what enhances our
Conservation Area and our Value Center
it positively contributes to our Health
and Social and economic well-being and
the sustainability of the borough in
these circumstances there are strong
planning grounds to support the
application if the council is not
seeking to serve our planning needs in
these sets of circumstances then as
residents we would question what
purposes are being planned for this is
an application request
that's it yes 10 seconds that it's
Representatives approved to enable the
public and Community benefit that it
delivers to continue thank you very much
for your time thank you Mr Sharma
councilor Sutton
thank you councilor you will get five
minutes thank you
thank you chair uh as members for awards
councilors Lester and Spencer and myself
agree on our support for this
application uh while we appreciate the
diligent work to work of officers and
taking aboard their comments there are
some areas in which we have
disagreements our view is that these
differences should have a pertinent
impact on the waiting and positive
negative aspects of this application
we value conservation areas and their
potential to protect and enhance some of
the most historically beautiful
buildings and areas but sadly they also
have the potential to become locations
people won't invest in due to the
possibility of too many restrictions we
know it's a balance of protecting places
while also enabling them to thrive to
improve and to innovate we think this
design does do that
firstly indications that the structure
is out of character with the
conservation area overlooking important
points this metal framed glazed shelter
is across the road from one of in what
the most important features of the area
which is the grade two listed large
metal framed glazed shelters of the
Railway Station itself along with the
similarly similarly listed cast iron
Footbridge
we also point to paragraph 34 and
suggest that the availability of this
all-weather seating and dining area to
the public with views across the heart
of the conservation Zone including these
Railway structures is a positive
contribution for how these Heritage
aspect assets can be experienced with
this paragraph also acknowledging that
the surroundings of Heritage assets do
evolve as such we consider the weight
given in paragraph one two two to be
inappropriate failing to appreciate the
extent to which the application makes a
positive contribution to the
significance of hail conservation Health
station Conservation Area while also
overestimating harm to aesthetic and
historic significance we feel that
paragraph one two five overlooks the
nature of the Railway structures
essential to the conservation area and
the paragraph 126 underestimates the
public benefit provided by the new
available Panorama review across the
heart of the area
our view is that the committee can
reduce the way to silence harm to the
Heritage assets and conservation air as
a whole and also assign some weight in
good benefits
we know that the report makes a point of
the owners not seeking pre-application
pre-planning advice when they open a
business at this location and that this
seems at odds with them now saying that
survival of the restaurant hinges on
year round outdoor weatherproof seating
but no pre-planning advice would have
prepared anyone for a pandemic that
hammer possibility sector Plus without
going into the causes a chronic lack of
hospitality staff massive hikes and
Commercial Energy bills along with high
inflation and supply chain difficulties
especially with high quality raw
ingredients Etc
the experience of the pandemic with
unprecedented steps just a furlough and
self-employment Income Support shows
acknowledgments at National level the
business plans written before 2020
should no longer be judged on their own
single swim merits is our view that the
viability of the building as able to
sustain business should not be judged on
pre-pandemic grounds and it seems unfair
to the applicants in their business in
such a position there are also post
pandemic trends at work including a
continuing continuing greater preference
for outdoor and open-air seating areas
the transparent glass cover in question
allows the terrorists to be used all
year round be it for casual drinks or
fall forward memorials the structurally
safe or whether the shelter it's the key
difference that now makes this business
viable
umbrellas such as those which featured
in a previous application would in any
case be unsuitable for ongoing needs of
any business just earlier this week the
location saw scorching genes sunshine in
terms of Thunder hail at the high winds
within a matter of minutes large
umbrellas on a first floor Terrace over
a road and the face of more extreme
weather conditions would be hazardous
we know that the council's corporate
plan includes the intended outcome that
all our businesses and town centers will
be supporters to recover and flourish in
an inclusive way Additionally the draft
tail Place plan sets out the objectives
of the council to protect existing
businesses
we find paragraph one two three which
seeks to separate the viability of one
business location from the longer term
success or failure of a High Street to
be at odds with these Council objectives
the business is busy and is currently a
viable one do we think that if planning
for this year-round terrorists was
refused and the business would fall
tomorrow probably not but the ongoing
challenges would likely be too much
especially with reduced opportunities
across the vital prisoners periods and
then repeat again with the new business
attempting in the same location the
geographical location of this business
and the nature of the restaurant brings
in customs from outside the borough
including from wealthy parts of Cheshire
and further Fields meanwhile the
business employees not only self-local
to help but people from across the
borough from the for these reasons we
believe it's within reach the committee
to assign a different highway to the to
the value of public benefits to the
borough thank you
thank you councilor before we move to
debate on the committee Miss curly would
like to provide some clarification
to clarify the number of letters of
support we've had for this application
the number 200 was mentioned uh by the
by the gentleman who spoken sport it's
actually 67.
thank you Miss curly is there any member
wish to speak on the application Council
Welton Council Minister Papa
thank you very much um I had never
really noticed this building before
um inhale
but when sibo opened I went around the
corner I think I was on my bike I almost
fell off I was like wow that is
fantastic look I want to go there I
think this is maybe this building maybe
a Heritage asset but it's not a
particularly impressive one in fact as a
building itself it's a little bit dull I
think what sibo have done is
made
uh a different kind of attraction in the
middle of hail that adds significantly
to the conservation area as councilor
Sutton has has eloquently outlined and
whilst I totally understand why the why
the officers have proposed um to refuse
this application I think that it is
within the remit of this of this
committee to actually
support the residents and support you
know the large amount of people that
really really really enjoy this and
think it is a positive contribution to
the to the conservation area I really
think the people who you know if people
are going to vote again you know to
refuse this they have to give us a
really clear idea of of uh of how this
vibrant restaurant
um doesn't contribute to the con to the
conservation area because I really can't
understand how that how that could be
and so I really do hope that we we we
um yeah we back the local community and
approve this today thank you
Council minutes
thank you chair
um I'm in complete agreement with
councilor Walton um I remember this
coming last time I was in favorably at
last time
um the amount of public support it has
um is usually applications that are the
other way in terms of the conservation I
don't think being a conservation area I
don't think it actually
um
effectively is negative it has a
negative impact I think it is the
opposite it has a positive impact I
think what they've done is actually very
good
um and I think it makes the place
somewhere that people want to go
um
the net the people residents nearby
um and
um and obviously further afield are
clearly all supportive of it I don't see
why we would say no to it
um and uh are you proposing you propose
I will be seconding that thank you
thank you councilor Council Baba
um thanks that you know you were not
driving otherwise you would have crashed
only fell off Dubai
it makes sense it looks amazing I think
it's a combination of something
traditional and contemporary it gives
you that look but you know it's a wow
factor
um if there is no detrimental
effect you know to the locality at large
I do not see any reason that why we
should not you know approve so I'll go
with you
thank you councilor councilor Taylor yes
I think from like a a building
perspective the Pelican I just off watch
I rode very pretty building but it's
derelict and abundant and do we want
another version of the Pelican whereby
we refuse this and the company goes
elsewhere we have a very pretty building
which is left alone to rot uh and as
somebody who represents the neighboring
Ward it's a bit like I know a lot of the
people who work at chivo live in my area
so I wouldn't want to see people who
work
within Trafford losing their jobs when
clearly the residents of the local area
support it most of us here have no
issues really with it it's an okay
building but it's nothing special no
offense to achiever
thank you Council for councilman
I've got no problem at all with the
metal and I thought a good pointless
Mage with regards to the reflection of
the Railway Station the amount of
plastic at the top of that building
um the false foliage you might have it I
just feel is so
I
think it's got a really negative impact
but I don't live there
um but I'd like to see less of that and
maybe more looking like as it is there
instead of all that mess of
artificial foliage and what have you
whether that's a dining issue that is
that is what you're approving
the foliage could come off early so what
you see there is what you are approving
I'm sorry
on the picture there yes that is what if
if members approve this this evening
that that is what they approved the meth
the decoration isn't development you'll
come off at any point so it is so that's
that's that as you wish to say is what
you are approving and that is what I
would say I would go for
oh
I I object to this I object to the the
change to the building in a conservation
area and anyone who's sat in this
committee with me before knows that I
don't believe in setting stuff in aspect
I don't you should change this and I
both have stopped in the past to vote
item for change item in the conservation
area we didn't ask for this to be set in
aspect we did allow a change to be made
to the building in line with the
conservation area this goes Way Beyond
anything which we approved and I think
it is absolutely detrimental to the the
general Conservation Area it jars when
you come down Victoria Road as I did on
uh Tuesday the the contradiction between
this building and the rest of the
conservation area particularly the
station which is a beautiful building
um it really does detract
um so I am proposing that we refuse this
in line with officer recommendation this
is a conservation area the clue is in
fact in the name
thank you Council Proctor
I was like to second that
it
apart from the nasty plastic
um decoration that was there on the last
application last year it doesn't look
any different
and it distracts from the building it
detracts from the area and so I'm happy
to second that thank you councilor
anybody else wish to contribute
cancer actually
um in reading the application I was
pleased to see that um
that Chiva will be replacing the
aluminum frames with with wood windows
and doors if I'm if I'm correct
um I think it does have a positive
impact on the local area and does that
um add positivity to the street scene
um as far as we understand the structure
that's been um erected can be quite
easily removed in the future
if there's a change of use or change of
business which gives me some assurance
that in the future it can be removed
without damaging the structure itself
um and just to Echo counselor Taylor's
comments as well by having a business in
there that's that's trading and making a
profit it means that that building will
have ongoing and continued investment
put into it um The Heritage asset
um will continue to thrive rather than
falling in some kind of a disuse
and so for me I I will be um voting to
approve the application
uh thank you so we've got to uh two uh
proposals on the table we'll take the
proposal to allow the application
first
uh against officer recommendation so all
those in favor of allowing the
obligation allowing the application
could you indicate now
make that seven
all those against allowing the
application
I'm like that five
and we'll take the Contra proposal to
refuse this in line with officer
recommendations to all those who wish to
refuse in line with office
recommendation indicate now
five thank you thank you counselor
and all those who wish to go against
officer recommendation and allow could
they indicate now
we will need to have conditions and
asexual 106 agreement to secure the
replacement of the windows so if you are
happy for officers to deal with that
matter then we will do so thank you
absolutely
yes
the next item is the
Kellogg building on Talbot Road there's
two items on associated with this Miss
Coley will do the introduction
thanks everyone
thank you
I think we're going to be all right yeah
so
um
these applications and we're going to
take two applications
um now relate to the former Kellogg's
office building instructed which is now
in use as University Academy 92 and it's
surrounding Land There are two
applications under consideration this
evening want to vary the housing mix on
the outline permission and the other for
Reserve matters pursuant to that same
outline so we've got a site Edge red
here on this plan that's the outline
that's the site Edge red for the reserve
matters the site Edge red for the
section 73 variation application is the
whole of the site as shown in your
agenda just just to make that clear
um although I'm introducing both items
together members must consider the
application separately and the variation
application needs to be considered a
first this is because the reserve
matters application depends on the
housing mix proposing the variation
application
so the variation proposes A variation to
condition 44 attached to the outline
planning consent this condition
currently requires a minimum of 65
percent of the approved residential
units to be delivered as accommodation
suitable for family living the applicant
wishes to amend this condition to
require a minimum of 59 of residential
units to be suitable for family living
the proposed variation of condition 44
is considered to be acceptable having
regard to relevant development plan
policies
the mixed Community envisaged under the
outline application would still be
achieved and the change from the
existing consent is not considered to be
substantial as such it's recommended
that the application should be approved
this will need to be subject to a
section 106 agreement to carry over the
106 obligations from the original
permission into this consent as an
application as a section 73 generates a
new planning position in its own right
the reserve matters application is
seeking approval for appearance
Landscaping layout and scale in respect
of the majority of the site covered by
the outlying consent this comprises the
direction of 639 residential dwellings
along with 529 square meters of local
Center uses and areas open space the
residential units comprise a mix of one
two and three bedroom apartments along
with three and four bedroom townhouses
and a spread across the application site
members attention is drawn to the
additional information report which sets
out the position in respect to the noise
environment experienced by Future
residents of the development following
the agreement of three noise conditions
which are set out in the additional
information report Lancashire Cricket
Club have withdrawn their objection to
the scheme
it is considered that with an internal
noise level of 40 decibels that although
residents will have to make small
changes in their behavior noise at that
level would be time limited and the
number of dwellings affected by the
loudest constant noise is less than 10
percent of the overall scheme the Agents
of change principle would be satisfied
and residential immunity would not be
effect adversely affected to such a
degree that it would alter the overall
planning balance
the proposals will cause less than
substantial harm to Heritage assets at
the lower end of the scale there will be
some elements to the design of the
scheme which do not fully align with the
council's design policy other harms
would arise from not every unit having
its own private outdoor amenity space
and for the loss of trees albeit this is
mitigated
however substantial public benefits have
been identified including the
contribution the scheme will be made to
the council's five-year housing land
Supply the provision of 15 affordable
housing and the regenerative benefits of
the scheme overall it is therefore
considered the adverse impacts of
granting Planning Commission would not
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits of doing so
um yeah that the reserve matters
application is therefore recommended for
approval thank you
uh thank you uh Miss Coley
um Miss Smith if you occur to speak
there's two applications are in front of
us so I think technically you get six
minutes but no one is going to be
obsessed if you only speak three
thank you
good evening members my name is rhianne
Smith and I'm the planning agent for
this application firstly I'd like to
thank officers for their hard work in
preparing comprehensive committee report
which addresses all relevant material
planning considerations and for their
recommendation for approval as I'm sure
you'll be aware the application site has
been earmarked by the council as a
long-standing regeneration project and
today is hugely important for the future
of this site if members Grant this
Reserve matters approval and Associated
section 73 a critical Milestone will be
achieved and an important step will be
taken in kickstarting the much needed
civil court and regeneration and renewal
as confirmed by officers in their report
the principal of the proposed
residential led development has been
established by the grant of the outline
planning permission and as such it is
just matters of layout scale appearance
and Landscape that are before you
a comprehensive Suite of technical ports
has been submitted with the planning
application and importantly no
objections have been raised by any
statutory consultes or Council officers
this is reflective of the comprehensive
and collaborative approach Glenbrook
have taken to work closely with the
council and statutory consulties through
the pre-application and determination
period to ensure all material planning
considerations have been addressed
including design Heritage daylight and
sunlight wind and Noise
members will know that concerns
previously raised by the cricket ground
in relation to the impact of the
development on their current operations
have been fully addressed and
appropriate mitigation can be secured
through the proposed conditions which
has resulted in the withdrawal of their
objection
The Proposal fully Accords with the
council's development plan when read as
a whole and will deliver substantial
benefits including the delivery of 639
new homes including 15 affordable homes
on a highly sustainable site this will
contribute significantly towards
addressing the identified housing land
Supply shortage and in turn will
increase household expenditure locally
and generate local jobs it will also
reuse previously developed land which
directly contributes to council's policy
aspiration to maximize the use
of such land for housing
it will act as a catalyst for future
development within the wider Civic
quarter enabling additional benefits
associated with this future development
to be delivered
it will also deliver significant areas
of publicly accessible open space
including neighborhood space and
informal play provision which will
secure significant recreational social
and environmental benefits as well as
approved appearance in this area
it is noted that subject to secure and
planning permission glenber are
committed to bringing the forward
forward the site at the earliest
opportunity of already secured the
necessary funding for the scheme
in summary the application is wholly
acceptable in planning terms and the
prose development will deliver important
regeneration in an area of Trafford that
is in need of investment it will act as
a catalyst for The Wider regeneration of
traffic's Norfolk northern areas and
create a new sustainable neighborhood
which will secure substantial social
environmental and economic benefits for
the Civic quarter and The Wider area of
Trafford I would like to thank you for
your time and respectfully Quest members
to Grant plan version in line with your
officer's recommendation thank you Miss
Smith
there's two parts to this that we'll
have to vote on separately the first
part is to is to change one of the
conditions so that the um
the the number of family homes on the
side uh on this side goes from 65 to 59
Renaissance means there's an increase in
one and two bedroom Flats on on the site
does anybody wish to speak on this this
aspect of the application before us no
in which case I'm happy to propose that
we accept that could have a second to
run that second okay so if both the
seconded all those in favor though we
accept that reduction
unanimous you none of this brilliant
should we now then move on to the second
part of this which is the
um the consideration of the
um the other matters on the site
um and this the reserve matters have
already been agreed on this this is just
the detail which is which is in the
report does anybody wish to speak on
this
councilor Welton
yeah it's I mean it's a massive project
people think we'll be waiting for this
for a very long time and it's great that
it's it's it's finally coming forward
and I you know I was
it's a big scheme it's hard to get you
get a handle on the whole of it the only
thing that I could possibly ask for
um from from reading the documents would
be some power generation and there
doesn't seem to be any solar provision
um on the site
um which is a kind of a shame given
we've just approved a site just across
the the tram tracks that does have it
but having said that there's a lot of
many many positives about this scheme
which given it's late I'm not going to
go into now brilliant thank you I'm
happy to second we accept office
proposal I love this game I think it's
beautifully designed there's so there's
so much about it
um and I particularly like the the
equality is impact assessments where we
talk about accessibility and homes for
Life a real a real um Plus for me so if
we propose a second that we accept it or
less the story is anybody else wants to
speak
okay proposing accepted the proposed and
secondly accepted all those in favor
please indicate
I'll make that unanimous brilliant thank
you
so that that moves us on to item 11 on
the agenda which is the
um verification of a hazardous
substances
um
order uh Miss Coney we'll give a quick
introduction to this
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you Miss Kelly
thank you for bearing with me there
um this application relates to a site at
the southern edge of the now largely
vacant Carrington Refinery complex uh to
the northeast of Partington two gas
holding Towers 12 cylindrical vessels
were located on the site but they have
been removed following the approval of
an application to demolish them
um so natural grid have applied
um to Trafford as hazardous substance
Authority which is one of our
um
formal designations to formally apply
for revocation of two hazardous
substances consents on this site
and they which are currently in place so
even though they've been demolished they
have to formally
um seek to revoke them otherwise the
consent stays in place
um so National Grid no longer require
the Hazardous substances consent
um the report sets out the replication
procedures under the under the Act and
the implications with regards to the to
the sub to the consents
um there are positive environmental
implications revoking the deemed consent
National Grid have confirmed they will
not seek compensation and indeed under
this particular type of process there
wouldn't be any but the secretary of
state has to confirm the order and we
understand the planning casework unit
are having seen the recommendation to
approve processing that now and will
continue to do so if members are minded
to go with officer recommendation this
evening thank you
okay so I'm happy to propose that we go
along with officer recommendation
second advice seconded by cancer acting
all those in favor
unanimous brilliant I started from the
agenda any urgent business of which
there is none so okay thank you for
attending the meeting is now closed
thank you councilors
foreign